I'm going to shout out to Steve Bannon
again because uh he told us a couple
months ago
that come August 15th when these parents
see what these these schools are doing
to their kids man it's going to be you
know it's going to be crazy we had
Bannon back recently and he said it was
actually crazier than he thought because
all these parents are rising up
everywhere there's protests everywhere
and it's not even just about the schools
though we're also seeing in basically
every city protest against vaccine
mandates in the workplace medical
professionals doing the same thing and
now we're seeing something that I didn't
even expect to be honest
students walking out of school refusing
to wear masks so I think there's good
signs here and you know there's you can
have your opinion on the mask thing and
all that but I think you know students
saying here's what we're accepting
here's what we're not accepting and
standing up and speaking out on their
own behalf it's a good thing
but I will add you know there's been a
many many instances of student protests
where the students typically just like
repeat talking points that the adults
have said so we'll bring to the story
and we'll see what these these young
high school students have to say about
this stuff and then we have other really
really big news which I gotta be honest
probably should have been the lead but
uh I decided not to go with it and it's
that CNN is reporting and I kid you not
according to a CDC survey eighty percent
of people surveyed above the age of 16
have immunity now that's massive and
this is I have a CNN article it is CNN
of all Outlets saying this and according
to Forbes one week ago heard immunity is
acquired at 60 to 70 percent so I'm not
definitively stating that we are at that
point because there's probably some
Nuance in here but big big news and we
will get into all this as well as a lot
of story about Texas and the Supreme
Court rulings and some of the crazy
stuff that's going on down there we got
Jay Leno capitulating to cancel culture
saying either Join or Die which is
creepy so we'll jump into that we got a
couple people hanging out with us today
we got Daniel Turner and Chris Carr but
uh you got you want to introduce
yourself yeah Daniel Turner
um uh Power of the future is my
organization energy environmental issues
uh but just love to talk about all stuff
in general and it's always good to be
gone so thanks for having me absolutely
man we got Chris who is the executive
editor at uh timcast.com we had an
amazing team of awesome rock star
journalists who are covering the issues
daily and hourly obviously I'm back by
popular demand so thank you for that as
people turn to the streets they said
Chris Carr nothing you gave him Chris
Carr so I'm thrilled to be here once
again yeah it was it was just supposed
to be Daniel but then you know people
are outside with with signs and Chris
Carter died
yeah yeah you gotta you got to push them
back yeah oh I'm here too hey what's up
guys glad to see you good good to have
you back let's talk chickens let's rock
and roll oh yeah we're going deep on
chickens before we are gonna have to
talk about chickens for sure maybe
sticking our fingers in cow's mouths I
guess
I hear it's quite lovely apparently
inside it felt good so yeah yeah hey
before we get started I got we got a
couple things first we're gonna shout
out timcast.com become a member there's
going to be a members only segment
coming up later after the show it
usually goes around 11 or so p.m and as
a member you get access to exclusive
member uh well you get the members only
segments but you get an ad free
experience and you're supporting our
awesome journalists and our executive
editor like you know Chris Carr for
instance so make sure you check that out
smash the like button subscribe to the
channel but I also have another shout
out to do you may have uh heard from you
may have seen our show we had with the
guys from fortitude Ranch back last year
this is a recreation and survival
community and I'm shouting them out
because they need help and I am involved
with fortitude Ranch um I'm big fans
they're cool people and they're looking
to hire so this is not like a sponsor or
anything but I want to shout it out
because they well I'll I'll just tell
you what's going on so Steve from
fortitude Ranch the guy we had on the
show he was exposed to sarin gas during
the first girl Gulf War and is
experiencing some health problems so
they're looking to hire an on-site
Fuller part-time additional Ranch
manager at their West Virginia location
and I will attest to the fact that this
place is awesome and if you watch the
video where we fired the the Barrett M82
50 uh yes 50 caliber
um that's where we were it's awesome
there's a range there's a dog there's
chickens it's a whole lot of fun they
say fortitude Ranch is a recreational
and survival community in good times
it's like a remote rural vacation
retreat but in a collapse in bad times
they turn into a survival Community with
run by professional staff it is a
veteran-run company and they strongly
prefer hiring military veterans or
experienced Law Enforcement Officers
they're not going to give out the exact
location but it's Northern West Virginia
about two hours West of DC if you are
interested please contact fortitude
Ranch from their website fortitude
ranch.com or send an email manager at
fortitude ranch.com this place is
fantastic I'm a big fan I am involved to
a certain degree so uh we we bounce down
there periodically that's like I said we
filmed a vlog there with the guns and
stuff and if that's if you've seen like
you fit the bill hit them up they're
looking for help and uh wanted to shout
them out but that being said let's jump
over to the first story we got here
after you smash the like button of
course
high school kids in Colorado
walk out of multiple schools after
refusing to comply with mask mandates
and here we can see one kid holding up a
sign that says my body my choice
interesting how that one works
the story from Cassandra Fairbanks
dozens of high school kids walked out of
a Denver area out of Denver area schools
on Thursday after refusing to comply
with a mass command imposed on them the
Thunder Ridge High School students held
sign saying my body my choice and told
reporters that those who are scared of
the virus should stay home after walking
out of class around 9 30 a.m they were
joined by nearby middle school students
and their parents students from Legend
High School in Douglas County also held
a protest against the Mandate here we
have a bunch of videos of people walking
out
the Tri-County Health Department
announced earlier this week to require
all students to wear masks even those
who have been vaccinated the local CBS
affiliate reports that they also
prevented individual counties from
opting out of Public Health orders the
order took effect on September 1st and
is expected to remain in place for the
entire school year now here's what
here's what they have to say
quote I believe that masks they're
they've been going on they've been going
for mostly two years now this is okay I
believe that masks they've been going
for mostly two years now this is going
to be the third year of my high school
career that's compromised I want a
normal high school career there if you
are scared you could stay home said
student Austin Knapp as they rallied
these people agree with me they hate
masks and I do too said another student
the Denver Channel reports that Thunder
Ridge High School students were joined
by Ranch View Middle School students and
their parents quote there's enough
parents and there's enough scientific
data to show otherwise this is just not
a necessary option that they have to
take and there are enough students that
feel the same way said parent Amy Ellis
now
I actually don't know all the daddy no
wine it's changed so much I honestly
have no idea I know there were some
studies saying they found limited
efficacy there were some studies saying
the real problem was being endorsed
because of recirculated air and there
was recently a study that said Yes
actually masks did reduce transmission
so I I'm not I I can't give anybody
advice on this stuff because everybody
claims to have the science and I don't
know but I can tell you this when Bannon
said parents would be mad
I don't know if he expected the kids to
get mad too and the kids to come out but
if the parents and the kids and this is
just one location you know I'm it's it's
cause for optimism we've got some good
news and this is a this is the first
time in the history of of civilization
that we have a plague or a pandemic that
seems to exempt children miraculously
right the Bubonic plague didn't do that
black death
SARS other other illnesses sort of Hit
the population equally this this for
some bizarre reason has not affected
kids and yet we're punishing kids like
we are are we're treating them like they
are as susceptible as as adults and it
does seem bizarre it also doesn't seem
to hit people without comorbidities
which is very strange yeah there are
kids who have died absolutely but the
number is very very small relative to
the highest risk factor is over 40. and
so if you look at the CDC data it it it
drops down significantly I think obesity
was a huge Factor the CDC says around a
third of all hospitalizations are obese
what I want to know is at what point do
you have covid and then be considered
infected with covid because the virus
can be there not hurting you at all well
then are you considered infected at that
point yes semantically you're infected
right so there's actually a lot of
viruses people have all the time but
there's they're they're asymptomatic I
was reading about I was I was I was
covering the uh the Ebola outbreak years
ago and zika and stuff that's why I
actually interviewed people at the CDC
and it was really cool actually they
explained how Ebola is a is a terrible
virus not because it's like physically
terrible and people are like but because
it's so aggressive that it becomes so
presentable that it stops the ability to
transmit they said good viruses are the
ones you have every day that don't make
you sick because they've successfully
infected you without triggering your
body's immune response and they're not
killing you so they can perpetuate so
covet's getting more intelligent as it's
evolving to Delta Which is less
intelligent isn't the right word or less
lethal but more in effective I think
that's the general trajectory of viruses
as far as I understand it at least it it
may be intelligent is the right word but
that is a good point basically the virus
is becoming more successful right it's
more transmissible and less deadly which
means more people are going to get it
they're they're going to experience
severe symptoms to a lesser degree but
they're going to get sick with it and
that's that's basically the CDC was
saying to me that
there's a lot of viruses that don't
cause enough damage to harm you so the
virus goes on forever and spreads around
like crazy but you know covet in its
earlier stages was was a bad virus like
it was it was bad for its own you know
propagation you know yeah and I can
understand where these kids are coming
from because when you are 15 16 your
your window of experience is is very few
years right um so every minute that is
lost feels like an eternity like being a
kid waiting for Christmas morning was
forever right if you've gone through all
of your the second half of freshman year
all of your sophomore year now you're
beginning junior year and you can't play
a sport you can't go to a dance you're
still I too would feel like I am losing
these very few precious high school
years and I'm stuck in a bubble I can
see them being protesting just just the
other day I looked at my watch and I'm
like it's September already like what's
going on I'm old you know so 35. wow
yeah I know I know yeah 35 man do you
still even though we're old do you still
get nervous when you see back to school
School commercials I saw one the other
day on TV and like my heart skipped a
beat like back to school and I'm like I
haven't been in school in 30 years and I
was like oh my God back to school I got
so uncomfortable 30 years oh yeah I'm
old really yeah are you gonna say we
established this last time I was here I
am 11 years older than you holy so you
have been in school for 30 years 40 uh
well I guess 20 something years all
right okay because I was like what are
you 50 no but it feels like 30. yeah the
one comment that really stuck out to me
in that article is if you're scared you
can stay home I thought that was a
really interesting point because I I
heard a family member recently say you
know they were explaining some of their
hesitancies to go out and experience
life and they said every time I go out I
have to be I have to be worried about
what's going to happen to me and that
just struck me so counterintuitive and
this kid's hit on something that's
really vital is just like if you're
scared then you can stay home that's
that's on you well we've we've inverted
the script you know now it's like if
you're scared you're hurting other
people and we should be allowed to go
out on being scared I mean who didn't
see this coming we had stories from
seven years ago about the the the foofy
neon safe spaces they're putting in
colleges where if you were triggered by
a lecture you could go inside and sit in
a bean bag and hug a plushie you think
I'm kidding this is real yeah they were
like pastel colors and then you could go
to therapy and they'd be like remember
that video where it's Nicholas christock
christakis I think his name is and I
think this is the incident where the
woman says college is not about
fostering intellectual you know right
conversation it's about creating a home
and a family in a safe Community or
something like that and it's like no it
isn't I remember that college is yeah
and that started as the therapy dog
during midterms because you needed to
comfort that were the point now although
that probably doesn't happen because of
covet but we're at the point now it's
like Ben Shapiro's coming to campus well
we have to we have to shut it down like
I'm I am and people will say real
college students college students how
embarrassing college students will say
like I am afraid knowing he's on campus
it's like well dude then you need to
just live in a closet the rest of your
life like if if Ben Shapiro you know
four miles down the road at like
whatever Hall giving a talk to the yaf
kids has you literally afraid then then
just you should end it right now because
you're never gonna survive in this world
isn't Ben like five eight yeah I'm not
trying to I'm not trying to be mean I'm
just pointing out like it's not a very
intimidating guy but to be here he
speaks very fast he does speak very fast
so that triggers you yeah and what
triggers is that he will probably like
he'll outwit everyone in the room five
times over because he is just very damn
smart oh those put him owning people oh
gosh that's so good that's so quick
that's what they're scared of exactly
like I gotta say when I when I saw Ben
on uh uh real time I was impressed yeah
oh yeah wow yeah I mean he's calmer than
he used to be too but then like when we
were in college I mean I I only did two
years of college I didn't graduate I'm a
College Dropout
um when I was in college that short time
and we had Noam Chomsky come to school
we had we had communists come and
lecture none of us were like I'm so
afraid knowing that this person is here
she's like oh you don't want I'm not
gonna go to that lecture yeah I think
that what they're really saying is that
they're triggered by him being there
yeah like they're not really afraid for
their life not I don't think so anyway I
hope you know do you know what triggered
actually do you know what afraid really
means
don't you guys understand what like a
trigger it actually is it's a real term
when someone has post-traumatic stress
disorder or you know whatever you want
to call it George calling is a great
business yes I think they got they got
rid of the disorder part of it now so
you know you go to war and you hear a
bang in the middle of the night you wake
up you're like what's happening and you
experience that for a long period of
time then you see your friends die and
then all of a sudden you're back in the
United States and a car back fires and
you break down you start sweating and
you're heart speeding like crazy that's
a trigger a trigger for and you need you
need someone to help you through that so
come back like we're not in the conflict
anymore so we've bastardize that now too
just things I find this this comforting
are now a trigger I mean even the rights
memified it they're like oh the left got
so triggered by this do you think that
Ben and others like him are like sure
triggering people like making them feel
like they're they're in second grade
again and it's that kid that's just
keeps talking to them and saying either
making fun of them or saying mean things
to them and then they feel that when
they see Ben because he's so like
poignant like straight through you well
it's funny that you say that because I
did have something I wanted to interject
that's not exactly on topic but I I
spoke with a military veteran who uh
he's 90 now but he spent 30 years
working with veterans that had PTSD and
he had no data but he had anecdotal
evidence when I spoke to him he said
Chris 90 of these veterans that have
genuine PTSD it didn't come from the war
it came from their childhood realest
practice and that's what I said I'd
never heard anything like that but in
the 30 years that he worked with these
veterans he was just like it's what
happened according to him is that these
kids had PTSD in childhood because of
traumatic situations they were in and
the war just blew it up you know you
know and I never got back interesting
I've not I've not been in like you know
hardcore full-scale Warfare with air
strikes or anything like that I've been
in urban conflict I've seen people lose
their lives and shoot at each other and
there have been bullets flying past me
and I would not say I've ever
experienced anything beyond like there
was one point where carback fired and I
had like an adrenaline rush and then I
was like whoa I gotta calm down and that
was the extent of it and so there are a
lot of people I've met in like hostile
trainings hostile environment trainings
and I've talked to about this and
they've explained that they've seen the
worst you could possibly imagine and
they don't have like negative impacts
from it like
you know I don't know I don't know what
that means but I think some people are
attuned to like make it through these
things without having you know like
issues or you know
post-traumatic stress disorder whatever
whatever's supposed to be called and
some people are heavily impacted by it I
don't I don't know I don't know what it
is very interesting I've never heard
that before but I mean going back to to
those kids though who are protesting I
mean more kids pre-covered died every
year from the flu in school and and
everyone said this argument a million
times we never shut down for the flu but
we didn't like you found out your
classmate had the flu and it was like oh
dude don't come to school you're going
to get everyone sick but schools didn't
shut down but we lost hundreds of
thousands of Americans every year to the
flu
and it was just kind of understood and
kids were susceptible to that I I do
think it's fair to point out though the
the long-term effects of covid the
potential long-term effects are what's
worrying and and to be fair what what
they're saying about young people is
that they're a transmission Vector so
the kids aren't the ones being impacted
but they're negatively impacting old
people and my response to this is like
since when do we have the young people
make sacrifices for the old people I
understand these are these are serious
issues and people are concerned and we
definitely don't want old people dying
we don't want anybody to die no but at a
certain point I mean I look at what
happened with with Fukushima in Japan
when the old people went and volunteered
to go into the you know to the reactor
to like shut it down knowing that this
was the end of their lives but they were
saying things like I'm gonna sacrifice
you know what I have left to help the
Next Generation and so what I'm really
what I really want to get to is here is
you know look I'm not a doctor I can
recognize that they're health risks
there are a bunch of stories about like
teenagers who lost taste and smell for
like a prolonged period I'm sure that
sucks but
you know I'm losing my train of thought
what was I going to say oh yeah yeah the
kids uh um the suicides that we've seen
spiking in certain countries and you
know whether it's it's one life or a
hundred there was a story of a guy uh a
guy I knew
um acquaintance he's a he's a tech uh
CEO his son killed himself because this
kid's I think he was like 10 years old
and he spent a year in lockdown yeah
basically solitary and everything his
friends life was stopped and I don't
think the adults realized what this was
doing to Children psychologically that's
10 of his life experienced in a house
you can't leave you can't go outside
everything's shut down you can't you you
can't that's what happened and
eventually it's just like the kid
couldn't take it I was I was uh really
surprised to hear the story to be honest
because like I the idea that these kids
were were you know pushed into that
frame of mind to me was crazy and their
parents are right there and there's like
ample opportunity for the parents to be
there with their kids and but we see
more and more stories about this adults
can handle this stuff better than kids
can and that's what we've got to be
worried about obviously we don't want
diseases spreading and covet sucks but
at what point are we going to be like
the lockdowns destroying the economy
nursing home stuff that Cuomo and these
other Governors did literally murdered
people how about we do the opposite we
allow the economy to function we put
some restrictions in place that protect
the elderly and the immunocompromise so
they're all you know taken care of and
then we make sure the nursing people
nursing homes aren't dying and the kids
can go there live their lives without
feeling depression and suicidal thoughts
and things well that was the purpose of
rushing the vaccine which I know is now
FDA approved at least one of them but
the purpose of the quick vaccine and
operation uh warp speed was to protect
the elderly it was four older adults it
was four older adults to say we don't
expect you Grandma Grandpa to live the
rest of your your golden years in your
living room so let's get a vaccine that
you can get back into society and that
has gone from let us get a vaccine to
protect the vulnerable to give your 16
year old and hell we don't you said you
don't know the long-term effects of of
of uh covid and I know renal issues have
come out now as a long-term effect what
is the long-term effect of of a vaccine
that no one knows the long-term effect
of right well let's let's let's jump to
the story from CNN my friends this is
big big news and they buried the lead no
joke CNN buried the lead check this out
so here's here's what it says mid
article CNN from today survey more than
80 percent of Americans 16 and older
have immunity the survey led by the CDC
also indicates that about twice as many
people have been infected with the virus
as have been officially counted more
than 39 million Americans have been
diagnosed with coveted infections since
the pandemic started in 2020. the team
led by the cdc's Dr Jefferson Jones set
out to determine how close the U.S might
be to some kind of herd immunity
although they do not claim to have any
kind of handle on that yet
they worked with 17 blood collection
organizations working in all 50 states
plus DC and Puerto Rico to test blood
covering 74 percent of the population in
the end they tested
1.4 million samples I know Ian you were
asking about the sample size 1.4 million
in July 2020 before any vaccine was
available 3.5 percent of samples carried
antibodies to SARS covid II that Rose to
11.5 by December by May 83.3 percent of
samples had antibodies to the virus most
of them from vaccination
epic now here's the funny part let's
what's the actual story CNN says U.S
states that have that had some some the
worst wait what
yeah
19 case rates in past week also reported
the highest rates of new vaccinations so
this is CNN.com we got it pulled up I'm
showing you got the News Guard wow
newsguard says CNN doesn't handle the
difference between opinion and news
responsibility thank you News Guard come
on the show someday that's a good call
out mind you
um but but this is it this is CNN health
and they straight up are saying eighty
percent of Americans 16 or older have
immunity let me show you this from
Forbes top U.S officials including fauci
previously estimated that herd immunity
threshold to be about 60 to 70 of the
population deeming that goal reachable
once vaccines were available yo it
sounds like the vaccines worked there's
a couple things real quick it sounds
like operation warp speed worked yeah
Joe Biden moved up the timeline and
vaccines by about a month sounds like
that worked and it sounds like now based
on CNN's reporting of CDC data of
reviewing 1.4 million samples 80 percent
have immunity due to the vaccines this
is this is cost for celebration right
everybody should be really happy about
this let the Roaring 20s begin yeah yeah
we're there let's do it my two questions
are one are these immunity have they
developed immunity for a different
strain like the alpha strain when we
have the Delta strain out now and two
have they developed partial immunity as
opposed to Total immunity are they
different can you have partial immunity
it's better to be considered immune it's
a good question uh they say this was all
pre-delta the researchers caution plus
they didn't measure the other part of
the human response one involving cells
in his T cells and one that might induce
broader immunity but knowing who has
antibodies can help inform public health
health efforts quote several large
Studies have shown that among
individuals who are Sarah positive from
prior SARS covet to infection covid-19
incidence is reduced by 80 to 95 percent
similar to vaccine efficacy estimates
they noted the study will continue until
at least December 2021 and results will
be made available on the cdc's website
they wrote you see
there we go that said the people that
have had it have also
they were referencing the other the part
of the study where it said that people
who have caught covid have similar
immunity to those who have been who have
been excellent this is the CDC you know
what at YouTube might not be happy with
us I don't know but this is good news
this regardless of politics this is what
we were aiming for two years a year and
a half ago and this is I mean ultimately
immunity is what we're looking for or
some sort of resistance I mean this is
amazing so in light of this news we can
expect for all the local and state
governments and the federal government
to start rolling back all their
regulations to start making adjustments
to the whole lockdown situation we've
been living through for the past 15 16
months there's nothing more permanent
than a temporary government we'll see
the populations making that happen as we
see in that with the kids walking out
exactly I don't I don't I don't know
what what you what what to say to you
other than uh share this with people let
them know the good news and I genuinely
mean this this is good news I think this
is fantastic this event absolutely 83.3
according to the CDC survey so we need
to start taking that consideration
because now it's time to bring the
economy back help our our kids get
everyone back on track and it's time to
celebrate declare Victory and to all the
the people who are uh you know I'll say
it right now all the people in the big
cities and all those Democrats who are
like vaccine vaccine vaccine
congratulations you did it you got
enough people vaccinated at least
according to this so far uh maybe it's a
little preliminary but if this if we're
basing our judgments off CDC data and
this is the survey led by the CDC well
then there we go baby that's that's it's
time to rot let's go to the movies fauci
came out on Fox news said that the moo
covet variant is not an immediate threat
to Americans I don't know if we're going
to talk about this story at all but
that's very promising as well because if
it's it's continuing to evolve this
virus and it's just according to fauci
not going to be a threat then it is a
good future I mean you know what it
sounds like it sounds like we had a real
risk with a novel virus that came out
last year maybe we overreacted some
people did really awful things like
Cuomo he's a bad guy and uh dude this is
what we said last year all last year the
issue was that because it was a novel it
was likely to spread rapidly and so we
were like we got to slow the spread well
maybe a year and a half you know and a
vaccine to slow the spread was a little
bit more than we thought was going to
happen but at this point do we now just
say like all right let's let's let's
start bringing things back let's bring
back the businesses the movies the
restaurants drop the mandates I think we
should put that on the table for sure
yeah for sure well this is so
interesting to me too because I think it
was just last week we were talking about
I think it was Thomas Massey tweeted out
a study about how natural immunity is at
least comparable to vaccine immunity and
he that tweet was super restricted you
couldn't respond to it this was an
Israeli study that had been
peer-reviewed yet and they were treating
it like it was absolutely lies and it
turns out that it definitely wasn't this
is entirely the case so they're not just
talking about vaccination here they're
also talking about like being recovered
from it I think that was the tweet that
someone tweeted at him like what would
you know you're not a scientist and he
tweeted back his diploma from MIT with
like masters in science
pretty damn funny I thought that was
pretty good I love him um but I guess
the question will be coming from this is
in terms of government in terms of
government overreach was all this for
our own good and and obviously there's
an argument about whether or not
government should even be caring about
our own good or it's about something
larger because if we're hitting this
herd immunity and we're heading in the
right direction and and and we're
celebrating and bring back the freedoms
Etc if if it doesn't start rolling back
well then you know this was all just a
load of of bunk right so that will be
the real question which I think has
people genuinely concerned I don't think
I don't think you're going to see
governments saying like hey look we
solved this problem and now everything
will go back to normal so that will be a
huge question I have I have I have a
question for all you guys uh you
mentioned that the Pfizer bionic vaccine
is FDA approved
I don't remember which one one of them
is well didn't one just get FDA approval
Community I believe I don't remember
which one it's a version Tim's probably
going to start talking a little bit more
about this it's a version of the Pfizer
bio and Tech virus uh vaccine called
Community it's basically the exact same
formulation but what they did is give it
a they gave it a name a proprietary name
oh and then the FDA approved that so the
Pfizer bio insect one is still not
approved even though it's the exact same
one so it's it's like the distinct legal
names have a difference but this matters
now I'll tell you why we have this from
the fda.gov FDA approves first covid-19
vaccine they say this is August 23rd
today the U.S uh the US FDA approved the
first covid-19 vaccine the vaccine has
been known as the Pfizer bioentec
covid-19 vaccine and will now be
marketed as Community for the prevention
of covid-19 disease in individuals 16
years of age and older community it's
called no it's Community
okay thank you the vaccine also
continues to be available under
emergency use authorization station
including for individuals 12 through 15
years of age and for the administration
of a third dose in certain
immunocompromised individuals so I guess
they're not they're advising bushes we
haven't gotten to the booster Point yet
I think some people have already gotten
them but uh they they do mention it is
uh that so basically the Pfizer biotech
vaccine
is going to be the same formula marketed
as community and that is FDA approved
okay let me read another paragraph for
you from fda.gov under Section 564 of
the federal Food Drug and cosmetic act
when the Secretary of HHS declares that
an emergency use authorization is
appropriate FDA May authorize unapproved
medical products or unapproved uses of
approved medical products to be used in
an emergency to diagnose treat or
prevent serious or life-threatening
diseases or conditions caused by cbrn
threat agents when certain criteria are
met including there are no adequate
approved and available Alternatives the
HHS declaration to support such use must
be based on one of the four types of
determinations of threats or potential
threats by the Secretary of HHS Homeland
Security or defense
okay
um
the Pfizer bioentec vaccine is approved
does that mean now that they've approved
this vaccine moderna and Johnson and
Johnson will lose eua that's my question
because what I read from you is from
fda.gov it's from the government website
let me let me show you got that you got
the News Guard certified right here and
this is this is really interesting news
guard says the FDA does not correct
errors they don't reveal who's in charge
what and they don't provide the names of
content creators that I find fascinating
but this is a government website yeah
all right we're supposed to be basing
everything off what the government says
we've got FDA approval they say in order
to receive eua there must be no
alternative
now I could simply argue this they all
already have emergency use authorization
it says it doesn't say you immediately
lose it oh come on
I mean okay so so you're not supposed to
give emergency authorization to these
other ones because they already had it
they're just it's okay well this is the
question I'm asking is the FDA now going
to come in and revoke that eua from
Modern on Johnson Johnson and just say
Pfizer is the one that's approved
because it is it literally is I mean FDA
said they approved I guess the question
is will they or and should they have two
different questions should they um there
is I don't think so there's a there's a
letter that from to the FDA explaining
that they are legally distinct even
though the same formulation because
marketing something under a brand is
specific but that doesn't change the
fact that there is an FDA so some people
said they're like oh it's not really FDA
approved because under a different name
and I'm like no there is an effective
alternative treatment available FDA
approved under Community oh but it's not
available yet Community right is it
yesterday you were saying it's not
available yet no no I don't know if it's
available oh okay I think people people
have said so I'm wondering you call your
doctor and ask is community available I
honestly don't know pretty soon there'll
be commercials absolutely but my
question is very very simple did moderna
and John are there stocks going to
plummet now I I would wonder if they
could make the argument again I'm not a
a pharmacologist I don't know but are
there different medical circumstances
where one vaccine would be preferable to
the other right now it seems like which
one are you going to get get like I
don't know CVS has the Johnson and
Johnson and Walgreens has I just no one
seemed to know which one they were
getting or why most people I know got
Johnson Johnson because it was one shot
right
um but otherwise they didn't know so the
only argument I would say is if they can
say for these reasons people who have X
Y or Z
genetic makeup I don't know even know
how to describe this sure they should
get moderna so even though pfizers is
the one pfizers is the one that's now
Community but you need Johnson and
Johnson for X reason so we still have
emergency youth authorization that's how
I would argue it so I've got this from
fda.gov this is a document says Pfizer
biondeck coveted vaccine eua Loa
reissued August 23. uh there is a
footnote that says the licensed vaccine
has the same formulation as the
emergency use authorization authorized a
vaccine and the products can be used
interchangeably to provide the vaccine
series vaccination Series without
presenting any safety or Effectiveness
concerns the products are legally
distinct with certain differences that
do not impact safety or Effectiveness
well didn't the one guy from the FDA
just leave to go join the board of
Pfizer that made the news the other day
and people were like well that's kind of
curious like you just saw that yeah so
you just left the FDA no no no that's
that's from years ago
I thought that was years ago really yeah
over two years ago two people did step
down yeah that was that was because
they're pushing for boosters before
they've been approved and they were
upset about that then I just saw that
also but now I'm gonna make sure it's
not thank you June 27 2019. former FDA
commissioner Scott Gottlieb joins Pfizer
board of directors oh I'm sorry you're
saying that the news is that Scott Lee
uh left the FDA now and went back to
Pfizer this is the guy that resigned
from the FDA just went back to Pfizer as
a story it says former FDA commissioner
Scott Gottlieb joins Pfizer's board of
directors and this is from 2019. okay
but you're saying he went from Pfizer to
the FDA I saw something that's uh so I
may have seen something that was not
accurate so that's why I don't even want
to continue talking to to be fair I saw
the same thing and I was a little
surprised too but I didn't read the
article and so the only reason why I was
one is bringing that up is to say well
then maybe that explains why one got the
uh the FDA approval and the other one
did it exactly not that we would ever
think you'd never see four-star generals
go work for Raytheon for example or yeah
there's never any of that like like you
know posturing between I I I don't I
don't say that story it could be that
we're Googling it but I see CNBC from a
day ago saying that he serves on the
board of Pfizer not the FDA so I think
maybe people got it mixed up do you see
the new vaccine for modern is going to
be called Spike backs no way really yeah
it's all four sorry
vaccines Spike Backs from moderna that's
the other people got tattoos of their
like teen vaccination
it's so weird yeah so to the bottom of
this community
maybe it's not available yet and that's
why they're able to continue the
emergency authorization use for the
generics possibly if Community is
available then by the fda's on standards
they've got to drop maybe they don't
have to drop the emergency because
they've already right they're not
allowed to continue to give more maybe
they're allowed to continue doing it
because revoking an eua is different
from it from giving one I keep laughing
because I already see the community
commercials and like the mother and
daughter making a pie and the dad's out
and they're like if you need to ask your
doctor about community and then they
list all the symptoms right like don't
take Community if you have boom boom
boom if you have teeth if you have hair
they actually do say in the in the FDA
approval letter and the product
information for Community there is no
information on long-term effects those
studies are ongoing and they're
currently undergoing trials so so people
have concerns about that and I think
it's funny when you see
um all the smears about horse medicine
and they're like oh you know ivermector
whatever which is not approved by the
FDA for use in treating covet nor is it
authorized in any way just so you guys
know because you know YouTube says it's
important
um
well I forgot I was going to say because
I was writing on YouTube
I don't know something awesome but oh
yeah yeah but they're they're you know
there are people who say like I'm
concerned about long-term health effects
and then they get made fun of and mocked
and ridiculed and I'm like
it literally says like here's what
really here's what bugs me I think too
many people who are have concerns are
getting their perception of the CDC
based on the Democrats and these
leftists I shouldn't say leftists but
like the Democrats in the establishment
left who say stupid things all the time
and the CDC literally gives you warnings
about the vaccine they tell you about
allergies they tell you about you know
uh counter indications they tell you
about all the data it's not like being
hidden on the CDC website the FDA said
everything I just read it's not hidden
on their website they're not concealing
these things yeah but you go to like you
know NPR and they're like Joe Rogan took
horse medicine and you're like that's
insane even even Oxford is doing a study
on Ivermectin which they say is
promising but not yet conclusive and so
I'm like okay here's here's what I said
earlier
regeneron is FDA authorized it's not
approved it's authorized that's
monoclonal antibodies that's what Joe
Rogan used Joe Rogan did a video where
he's like yo I had covet I was feeling
really bad so we threw the kitchen sink
at it we did monoclonal antibodies we
did Z Pack we did Ivermectin and there
all these Outlets are insulting Rogan
over uh over Ivermectin when the first
thing he says was monoclonal antibodies
which is regeneron now my question is
there is an emergency use authorization
under general not full approval as a
treatment for people and I think they
recently authorized it for potential
prophylaxis meaning like you can take it
to try and prevent as well if people if
if so my question is if people really
believe Ivermectin is as powerful and
potential and potent as it is in dealing
with this
why wouldn't the FDA just give it an
emergency use authorization you know
people are saying that the reason
they're they're not you know taking
Ivermectin seriously is because they
want everyone to get vaccinated and I'm
like but regeneron's available and
that's what Joe Rogan and Trump and many
other people used and it works and or I
should say we believe it does and the
FDA says it can be used so why not just
do an eua for Ivermectin if they really
had the data to back it up why not ask
yourself seriously why are you so eager
for Joe Rogan to be sick with with covid
right like he comes out and says this is
what I did and it seemed to work and
people were like I wish you had died
instead like what is this the strange
desire for him not to have succeeded in
what if if someone if one of you told me
you had coveted and you ate a lot of
bananas and you were like in the next
day I felt great I'd be like that's
really cool like I don't know maybe
maybe bananas work so I don't understand
this Fascination like like they want him
to be sick to just not break the
narrative uh and it's very bizarre
something we've noticed people have
gotten so mean we've gotten to the point
where people would actively like wish
that you just disappeared one way or the
other like why that's it that's uh I
don't I don't know what's going on I
think I can answer I can answer your
question from earlier about uh why is
things like Ivermectin not being
emergency authorized if but other things
because it's the same the same question
give you the same a different question
give you the same answer is why is
Pfizer creating a name for the the
vaccine called Community for profit
because someone owns that IP and they're
gonna make massive amounts of money off
the selling Community instead of the
generic version you can't make money off
of generic medicine yeah you not really
big money though you know you can't own
the IP so this Ivermectin stuff is like
some generic dollar for 20 I don't know
how much it costs but it's Dirt Cheap
compared to what but it is mass produced
by people and I guess the problem I have
with this is you get you start getting
the argument that well the studies must
be faked it's like well so here's what
we have we've got a bunch of studies
that are that are are pushed by uh that
are propped up by a lot of people about
the efficacy of ivermectin they show
country by country data and then you
have many other studies saying it's not
effective and we found nothing
I would have to make the assumption that
one of those like groups of studies
would be wrong or intentionally lying
and so I think we don't have to get
conspiratorial on it if we have data
saying regeneron is effective and Joe
Rogan took it and it worked although he
did take zpac and Ivermectin so you can
people might judge whatever they want to
judge obviously the media is claiming it
was the horse medicine the whole time
but if if we have you know data that
these things do work then I think it
makes sense to say we don't want to do
an eua on aforementioned because it's
conflicting data right now so imagine if
imagine if they came out and there's you
know we had Dr Chris Martinson he's a
smart guy and he said that look at all
these studies saying it works and then I
was like look at all these studies
saying they found no nothing no change
no positive fact it literally had no
impact and you know the response we got
from him was basically like oh yeah well
those studies you know you can't those
are no good and I'm like I'm I can't
make that decision I'm not I'm not the
guy who did the studies I'm not a Master
of the Universe I don't know everything
I see the studies and I see conflicting
data now imagine you are trying to
recommend people because you want them
to be healthy and you can choose to say
this one's got conflicting data this
one's got data showing it's it's
efficacious and regeneron also which
would you recommend I think it's it's
you can either believe in in the like
the the malice of people and the profit
motive and the greed and assume they're
just lying to people about these other
medications or I think you can make the
least amount of assumptions and say
someone looked at it was like I don't
know if that one's going to work I don't
want to recommend it right yeah yeah
also keep in mind that companies that
are producing products for profit often
will not test against them intentionally
you know you don't have to spend the
money to do the test to find out
everything's bad and but there's no test
showing it's bad then there's no
evidence that it's bad all the FDA
though right we had a study on
timcast.com talking about the efficacy
of I think what was it moderna and
AstraZeneca we read a study and it was
like they worked against Delta that
wasn't a study that was done by the
companies so look I don't like big
massive multinational corporation I
don't typically trust them or massive
governments I think they tend to be
utilitarian I think corporations are
very driven by profit they want to make
money but I also think what am I
supposed to do as a regular person to
all the regular people out there who are
trying to navigate this world keep their
kids safe when it's like you've got
people for competing political interests
and tribal reasons trying to tell you to
do something or not do something and
that's why I tell people when it comes
to all this stuff yes I genuinely mean
it when I say go talk to someone your
trusted doctor and if your doctor is not
someone good find one you trust because
the culture war is tainting everything
and making it hard for people to
understand reality yeah so I'll put it
this way I don't have the answer I don't
you might you might have an opinion on
the answer I just don't have it I
literally don't but I think driving this
also and making people distrust their
doctor the CDC the FDA the government
Etc there is a huge lack of
accountability as we learn more about
this virus and what I mean by that is uh
early on we have to get hospital beds we
were building hospitals we sent a boat a
Navy ship up to Manhattan because
by this weekend we will have forty
thousand respirators we asked Ford to
stop making cars because we need we need
a hundred thousand respirate those
things never came to fruition but my
point is like how come we never hear the
CDC be like hey look early on we thought
this turned out not to be the case but
now we know that every time they are
asked about those things it's like we
are not false we never make mistakes and
so people don't trust no I completely
agree
um when I when I look at the CDC and I
Look At You Know Joe Biden brought it up
Tuskegee right actually he insulted the
Tuskegee Airmen which is something
totally different very different than
not the Tuskegee experiments but but he
brought it up referencing that there
have been things in the history of this
country that made people distrust
government boom I can respect that and
then you have people who distrust
massive corporations I can respect that
find yourself a trump supporter doctor
then like if if I'm not saying you're a
trump supporter necessarily I'm just
pointing I'm just speaking generalities
if you've got the Democrats who are just
like I the craziest thing is they tell
me you know Casey neistat he's a good
dude uh I think he's a nice guy but he
tweeted out that he just pulled up to a
parking lot and stuck his arm out the
window and I was like you didn't consult
your doctor about like I think that's
bad I think you need to do that and then
you have on the other side people saying
yeah well doctors are dumb and I'm like
then find a doctor who's not dumb like
you're not the culture war is not your
place to take care of yourself man
people are manipulating you you've got
people on in every possible faction
trying to convince you that they're
right they should join them for some
reason or another and that means they're
going to try and get you to get you to
trust certain things and distrust
certain things and that's why I think
individual and personal responsibility
across the board that's what I'm all
about so but you know what doesn't help
that is when you have like last week 75
doctors in California walked out in
protest because we are not going to
treat the unvaccinated
um you have a uh a clinician who
wouldn't give Candace Owens a Cova test
yesterday right because I don't like
your politics right so when the members
of the community with the Hippocratic
Oath are now violating that for politics
that makes people not trust pop not
trust the profession but I agree they
did so much those doctors did so much
damage to the field of medicine but
there are a lot of medical workers that
are protesting the mandates yeah so so I
think my answer is simple then like uh
it would you trust a conservative Trump
supporting anti-woke doctor
would you would you trust a doctor
that's confused by politics at all oh I
didn't want their hands on me if they're
thinking about Joe Biden we we've had
people on the show who have talked about
how their doctors are like
staunch conservative Republicans and
Trump supporters and and gave them all
the pros and the cons knew all the
stories knew all the data knew what the
CDC had been saying about alternate
treatments and then made their
recommendation
I I I think we've reached a point where
the culture war is so entrenched in
every aspect of every institution it's
very difficult to navigate this stuff my
fear is just that like you know I I go
on social media
and I see the horse medicine thing where
they're like smearing Joe Rogan as if to
imply that Joe Joe Rogan went to Tractor
Supply and bought you know some some
tube of what's called like Aver
avermectin paste or whatever and then
you stick it in the horse's mouth that's
not what Joe Rogan did Joe Rogan's a
very wealthy celebrity I'm sure he's got
a team of doctors and they showed up and
he was like heal me and they were like
yes sir and they started to go no I'm
sure he went to the doctor and he was
like what should we do and they were
like let's throw the kitchen sink at it
to imply that he went to a tractor
supply instead of a Walgreens first
prescription is insane and it makes
people distrust everything and
you you can't let the political agenda
and the manipulators
screw with you you know what I mean I I
think you've got to separate yourself
from the culture War you do your own
research you go and talk to a medical
protection practitioner someone that
your family knows and that you trust and
you have a conversation about it for as
long as you need to have it I think it's
also important is to not get triggered
by the misinformation because I I I want
to sometimes like it makes me kind of
angry but if just don't don't get angry
by it let it happen yeah it's the
confusion that makes me angry like I
feel confused and conflicted and then as
a result I feel angry but you see in in
in the culture War there is a goal among
I think it's particularly The
Establishment to be quickly honest which
wraps up the Democrats it used to be the
Republicans but they when Trump came in
and broke the door down they want you
confused makes you easier to control
makes you frustrated scared and say I
give up and that's why I'm like don't
give up do research and then find
someone that you trust who's like look
if you do facts checking and you know
something has shown something isn't go
to your doctor ask them the questions
and if your doctor's wrong about some
like very obvious fact then you have a
bad doctor so I I said it before about
like hiring a plumber who can't fix a
toilet like why would you not want to
hire that person and I admire what
you're saying and I grew with what
you're saying um you are much more a
non-partisan than I am but I think part
of driving the culture War as I see it
is heck last weekend uh Deb Highland
Secretary of the Interior got married
went back to uh New Mexico Elizabeth
Warren was there New Mexico has a no
more than 10 people indoors masked at
all times all these photos leaked
Senators the Secretary of interior the
governor no one's wearing a mask they're
all doing the chicken dance they're all
having a blast at the wedding and it's
like if you're the enforcers of this law
that is supposed to protect us and you
know just like you don't really have to
follow it well then so I I get it like I
I wish the culture War wasn't so
prevalent but when you see stuff like
that that I think tends to come from one
side of the aisle
I don't trust a lot of what's coming out
and it's hard for me to get past it I
mean it's hard for me to get past it
when you see that commonplace I'll say
that I trust the CDC and the FDA
substantially more than I would trust
the press or any one of these government
officials or Barack Obama and I don't
have a lot of trust in government
institutions regardless of the CDC or
the FDA elected leaders I don't right
right I just don't but they're they're
so uh I I lean towards the benefit of
the doubt in terms of and and maybe to a
fault because I know the history of this
country I think I love the meme where
it's like if you trust the government
you haven't been reading history and I'm
like dude the challenge is for regular
people not for those who are hyper
partisan there's regular people who are
sitting at home and they're like I see
what do I do and it's like you've got to
get yourself away from the battlefield
where everyone's slinging ideas and the
news is constantly and in conflict and
people are saying you're a liar and
there are people who are sitting there
watching everyone accuse each other of
being liars and I hear that they go both
sides are bad and I'm like that's that's
fundamentally false there is like
conservatives who disagree on certain
things but we'll be honest with you and
the left that has no visible principles
in many regards like particularly with
what's going on Texas
and that's why I think people need to
remove themselves from it yeah and I
love in the culture where the amount of
Kafka traps we plant now it's like you
are a sexist and only a sexist would say
you're not a sexist and it's like wow
that's that's great so that's it like we
just deal with each other like that on a
regular basis now in the culture War you
can remove yourself to a certain degree
and what I mean is if if you don't have
faith in your doctor find one you'll
have faith in but what is for instance
let's say that you have a doctor a
series of doctors that just pair at the
same talking point without any proof for
instance my wife is pregnant we go to
the doctor is the vaccine safe the
doctor says the vaccine is safe and
affected and effective for pregnant
women but if you go to the FDA website
and I saw this this is after the
approval and uh this is uh let me pull
it up here
and it says
fda.gov
let me try and Google search available
data on co-mernity you have to slur when
you say that available data on community
administered to pregnant women are
insufficient to inform vaccine
Associated risks and pregnancy and it
goes on to say that there's no evidence
that that immunity is going to be passed
on through breast milk but the doctor
will say that you know so what do you do
are you just stuck in a state of
confusion and you don't know what to I
mean I I mean that's a that's a
legitimate concern that I have did you
show the doctor that data from the FDA
no no this was months ago when the
doctor said that but this is just a
brand new document that came up after
post approval so this is uh fda.gov we
have it right here it says available
data on community administered to
pregnant women are insufficient to
inform vaccine Associated risks in
pregnancy a developmental toxicity
toxicity study has been performed in
female rats administered the equivalent
of a single human dose of community on
four occasions twice prior to mating and
twice during gestation these studies
revealed no evidence of harm to the
fetus due to the vaccine and then they
have animal data so it sounds wife's not
a rat right just making no no no no no
but I can thanks for asking though yeah
so so this is simple if if you go to a
plumber and you say something like you
know the pipe in the back of my toilet
is broken and he goes what do you mean a
pipe they use small miniature aqueducts
you'd be like that's the most insane
thing this guy's gonna do was talking
about right so if you go to a doctor and
he doesn't he hasn't actually read this
stuff like well I would think that he
would at least try to protect himself
legally and say there's no evidence at
this point in time to say that this that
it's not effective or you know but he
just parroted the talking point you know
and I think that there's a lot of that
happening and I don't think that these
doctors are necessarily malevolent I
think that they just might be to some
extent ignorant it's interesting it says
there there's insufficient uh they said
data available data is insufficient to
inform vaccine Associated risks in
pregnancy so right I you know but the
FDA did say that it was safe for what
for pregnant women the fives are safe
and effective uh I think all of them say
that yeah yeah they did say the FDA said
it was safe effective than the FDA said
it was indetermined if it was safer
effect this is the packet insert so what
would I have pulled up this uh 20 Page
thing is like what they give you when
you receive the uh you know the vaccine
warnings and precautions adverse
reactions and I gotta be honest the
adverse reactions are overwhelmingly
like your typical vaccine reaction it's
like you get your headache and then
you're fine sore arm for a day or
whatever that we get we've gotten
vaccines before
um but but it does say that so I guess
my only concern is why the the Pfizer
insert is conflicting with what the FDA
is advising and that's why I just say
like
I can't explain it to you and you
shouldn't expect me to and I don't think
it's responsible to go to internet
personalities to try and figure this out
and if your doctor doesn't even know
about this it's very very difficult you
got to bring it to the doctor and they
often don't have time or interest in
reading it but sometimes they do and
they'll learn and they'll be like oh and
then they'll start teaching their
patients the new information I just I
just I think it's time to take
responsibility like the idea that you
could just go to a doctor and assume
they're they're they're good at their
job the idea that you should go to a
journalist and assume they're telling
the truth no no you gotta find good
journalists you got to do your research
you got to fact check now you got to go
and actually seek out those
professionals who you know and trust who
are going to take care of you the
novelist that's not me the novelist John
Gardner said something I've never
forgotten he said 87 of all people in
all professions are incompetent so to
find that 13 you know you got to dig you
got to work wow well I mean at least 50
or below average right yeah
actually one of my favorite statistics
that I was there is a statistic of
something like 73 of Americans think
they're above average looks it's like
well
a lot of math problems right there right
so yeah I guess you know 87 is right
that's a daunting statistic I don't know
not totally I think it might be accurate
let's bring up uh let's let's bring up
some of this uh uh hypocrisy from your
traditional liberals and we have this
story from Daily Mail liberal Supreme
Court Justices tear into their
colleagues for their quote flagrantly
unconstitutional decision not to
challenge Texas abortion Banwell Biden
calls it an insult to the rule of law
which is my question
there's a bunch of people standing on
the Texas state capitol or whatever and
they're chanting like hands off my body
why does that only apply to abortion and
not vaccines
don't know
politicism politics yeah exactly exactly
I mean I I do think I I know I'm getting
cynical as I get older um they are both
huge industries that have a lot of money
and a lot of 401ks and a lot of the
abortion industry is an industry the
pharmaceutical industry is an industry
and they have vested interests that go
much deeper than just the cause I wish
they would just to be honest and not use
the argument and it would fly better for
people for someone like me right instead
of coming out and saying my body my
choice like those those high school kids
and those middle school kids were saying
the exact same thing I'm like okay what
about vaccine mandates and they're like
shut up that's all all the response on
Twitter when I tweeted this was all the
all the establishment left types were
just like Tim Poole is a dim fool and
they're like high five each other and
I'm like you're not you're you're not in
this conversation that's a bad one good
one guys that was actually that one's
the classic That's a classic yeah yeah
the one that I think is the weakest is
PIM tool it's like come on you can do
better than that no yeah you you're
throwing some Rhymes and they did a
little rep now the point is if you don't
have an argument
you've lost yeah and they don't have an
argument and so if someone if someone
said
um I think the government should manage
vaccines and I think I should be allowed
to you know terminate a pregnancy it's
that simple I'd be like okay like I
disagree with you instead they're like I
don't think the government should force
women you know to have medical decisions
over their bodies and I'm like you don't
believe that you're using some kind of
liberty-minded talking point to trick
people who want freedom yeah they
definitely don't believe that because
they will be the first ones to say like
Let It Rain mandates if people have said
people have said on social Let It Rain
covet mandates right so so they don't
believe that as a principle
um they just believe it as a political
talking point this is the thing you know
so it's like when I'm tweeting people
like why aren't you criticizing
conservatives and I'm like well because
they were honest with me about what they
want to do they didn't lie they said
straight up you shouldn't be able to do
it and I'm like okay are you saying you
should I think the government shouldn't
intervene and have control over my body
and I'm like oh okay so you're
protesting the vaccine minutes no so you
don't think what you just said yeah just
tell me honestly yeah I think the issue
is the issue of abortion is extremely
unpopular uh like I I should say
Obviously the issue itself is unpopular
talking about it but most Americans
don't like it they just don't like it
and I think even when it comes to like
pro-choice groups it's always like with
heavy restrictions and now you have this
faction of far leftists who are they're
not even pro-choice they're pro-abortion
actively like CBS CBS News actually
calls them pro-abortion groups I was I
was you know reading this and they say
pro-abortion I I have a good friend from
Ireland
who told me who knows American politics
pretty well and so the reason why it's
never going to be resolved here is
because he said in Ireland and Catholic
Ireland gay marriage and abortion were
decided by referendum and he said and
even people who disagree with them know
the majority of people voted a certain
way and he's like we don't have
arguments about abortion and gay
marriage he said in America you have
them non-stop because the people never
felt like they had a chance to voice
their vote and I think there's a lot of
Truth to that I mean the abortion our
argument and even the marriage argument
no people ever got to just now I think
if you gave people the option to to
choose I think marriage would pass
pretty easily and I think abortion would
probably pass but I think it would be a
lot closer but but people would at least
say like I participated in this process
which does governance Society but that
didn't happen a court case happened and
now the nine justices heck Elizabeth
Warren we could some of the most Salient
things that I even tweeted at her when
she said that we need to codify Roe into
law to stop this from happening I'm like
so you're admitting it wasn't a law yeah
and and if it's not a law then the
people whose duly elected legislators
represent them in that and the Congress
they never participated in the process
and that's that's thoroughly Un-American
that this these these nine justices are
deciding something this concept happens
very often all the time non-stop right
non-stop that's why the left loves
that's why everyone loves the course but
that's why the left really loves the
courts because they never have the
political will to move these agendas
forward so they have to do the through
the courts when it came to the eviction
moratorium the Supreme Court was like oh
don't look at us that's Congress yeah
but many other issues they're like yes
it wasn't even Congress it was the CDC
all of a sudden you're like I don't know
the CD they said they said that Congress
has to kind of yeah exactly but even
suddenly the CDC director gets to make
rent you know I I saw you Tweeting about
that when you were like this is just
this is my parents retirement yeah it is
yeah it is and people are ranting
against landlords when the issue has
nothing to do with landlords it has to
do with people who took that money from
the coveted relief funds and spent it on
other stuff or saved it instead of
paying their rent your parents are rich
Fat Cats yeah you're just sitting on all
these properties and tell me about that
geez Florida Senate says legislature
ready to replicate Texas abortion bill
so this is interesting because what the
left is saying now is it's effectively
the end of Roe v Wade that women are
losing their rights and every Republican
state is going to do this and it's like
but you can still get an abortion but
isn't this just like a at some level
just a reactionary move from you know uh
consequential red States against the
vaccine mandates in blue States and blue
cities the abortion thing yeah no no you
don't think so no Republicans are
pro-life yeah but it also feels like a
political reaction
I I don't think so no I think not so I I
know exactly what you're saying and I
agree with you I don't think it's
necessarily abortion as a reaction to
covid but I think red States is a
reaction to the culture wars and the
byte Administration red states are
getting red like like really red and
blue States aren't getting Bluer they've
always been we can you get anything
Bluer Than current California New York
right like you you can't right but I
think red states are really getting
redder and I joked you know if the best
thing that this this life bill can do in
Texas is that it will keep them from
getting more Californians well you know
which was probably good for Texas people
are saying they're going to leave yeah
good we'll go back to California you
know and that's fine that is the 10th
Amendment that is the spirit of our
country and I I am pro-life I admit that
but if you want a pro-choice State make
your pro-choice state I'm just not gonna
live there but that's awesome I'm I'm
clearly married to it well I'm clearly
married but I'm married to a guy so
clearly I'm I'm pro-game marriage but if
Alabama doesn't want to have a gay
marriage I'm not living in Alabama is
that right I think that's unfortunate
for Alabama because Andrew and I are
awesome but that's the joys of states
rights you live in Alabama and do all of
the Alabama you want this is this is
really interesting that these kind of
things come up though is because the
Supreme Court made rulings no offense to
Alabama by the way sorry I just I threw
out of state by by I I don't mean to
interrupt you I just I'm not dig I love
the stuff Virginia I love the South
loving V Virginia yeah the argument from
uh promise the miscegenation the
proponents for miscegenation laws was
that if these states want to ban
interracial cohabitation in marriage
then don't live there and so there were
like my family for instance my mom's had
forced to flee different states when
people found out because it was
literally illegal for them to be in a
relationship I think that makes no sense
and so the Supreme Court said it
violates the Constitution the supreme
law of this country to tell someone for
these reasons that are arbitrary and so
I think the same thing is true of gay
marriage I think if
you know we're going to uphold someone's
constitutional rights right to privacy
and right to life liberty Pursuit of
Happiness and the privacy of their own
home makes sense for the Supreme Court
to say you can't do this as per the
Constitution and that means sometimes
things happen you don't like yeah
sometimes they'll there'll be some
Supreme Court rulings you're like man
that one's bad but uh you got to trust
that I guess you gotta you gotta trust
that to um
when we when we vote we get good judges
and then you know you're doing your your
civic duty to get Supreme Court Justices
appointed the the main issue that I see
is the Democrats talking about stacking
the courts because they've lost it
they've lost the argument and that's
when things go south because right now
if it's like if the Supreme Court issues
are ruling I don't agree with we get
active and we say okay we're gonna fight
you know politically to to change hearts
and minds and win the causes we do want
but if they say they're going to stack
the courts then the process is done
there's no path by which you can win
other than just manipulating the system
and that's the collapse that is the rich
obnoxious kid whose birthday party you
invited to who had a win because it was
his birthday party and every time he was
losing they would change the rules so
that Timmy won because it was his party
you know and that's exactly it there are
Democrat Senators who are blasting the
filibuster as a relic of Jim Crow when a
year ago Senator Tim Scott who is Black
who's a republican they were
filibustering his Criminal Justice
Reform Bill the same Senators who
filibustered a black Republican last
year are now saying we can't have the
filibuster because it's full of racism
and Jim Crow Democrats man so you but
you just can't change the system when
you lose and sometimes you lose
we lost in 2020 right we lost in 2018.
I'm we being Republicans I'm not even a
republican but I'm trying to make a
point right sometimes you lose and and
that stinks but you got to re-rally the
Troops you got to have better messaging
and better conviction and better
but you can't just change the damn rules
every time the year is not 2003.
we are not living in the era of the
neocons anymore the populists right the
the Maga crowd the Trump supporters they
they stormed the Republican party and
it's very different from what it used to
be but there's still many establishment
and neocon Republicans that are still in
office and I'll tell you this
I I don't like the Republican party
because they are spineless weak and they
just do nothings why should I care about
a group of people who don't do anything
and are bad at it I disagree with a lot
of them on their ideas I can agree with
some of the rhetoric around freedom and
then I like some people who ran as
Republicans but are clearly much more
libertarian like Rand Paul or Thomas
Massey but I view the Republicans as
what are they doing tell me you know I
remember
back when Trump was being impeached and
stuff I was talking to my mom about this
and she was like you know I don't hear
you talk about the Republicans at all
all that often I said oh what they do
when in 2016 when they had control of
everything what did they do oh they were
on board with Russia gate oh okay so my
complaints about you know russiagate
involved them the Democrats are evil
you know and maybe it's a little bit
hyperbolic to say because not every
single person who's running as a
Democrat is a bad person there there are
a decent amount that you know handful
that are good people just like the
Republican party has theirs but when you
look at how they lie cheat and steal
over and over and over again yeah I know
the Republican party was the exact same
way it was the uni party they were the
same thing but the Republican party is
something way different now it's a mess
you know you've got populist right-wing
individuals that are running for
congress who's going to make a very big
change and then you've got the populist
left that is coming to the Democratic
party and I think they're authoritarian
crackpots at least with the with the
wave of right-wing populists they tend
to be more libertarian
so so I'll tell you what my concern is
Democrats saying vaccine mandates I'm
like oh okay you're an authoritarian and
here take the government mandated
medical procedure regardless of what
your doctor says is insane to me no
medical or religious exemptions that's
insane it's an infringement of your
constitutional rights Texas and Florida
red States they're like no we're not
going to do any of that no that's not
true this this abortion thinks a
violation of your constitutional right
to get an abortion in my opinion you
have a constitutional right to get an
abortion I mean you have freedom there's
no nothing says you can't
what do you mean I mean the course ruled
you know you're allowed to so I don't
think they said it was a constitutional
right
last 50 years but it's not it's I mean
the Constitution is pretty it's been
interpreted it doesn't mention it it is
authoritarians to come in and say we're
going to make it so you can't now
because it's my spiritual belief like
get off my back dude
hmm but even even this this case though
I mean it's it's getting blown out of
proportion that this is now the
beginning of the repeal of Roe and it's
really not this is the this is the
courts saying
you filed suit against a law that hasn't
even gone into effect yet and and you
don't have the right this is a little
premature like like don't don't shoot
your load just yet let's actually let
the sorry that was really vulgar I
appreciate it personally as soon as I
said it I was like oh my god did I just
say that I'm so
for weeks
but anyway I I think I think politics
being politics this is getting blown up
as like that's it row is now over and
this is the court saying
um let's actually have a challenge to
the law before you bring it to the
Supreme Court just saying this land law
can't go into an effect yet there needs
to be someone who who is negatively
impacted by it can be able to challenge
it yeah yeah so that's that's what
people don't realize is the reason why
the lower courts were like nah and
Supreme Court's like nah well so the
lower court said we're we're letting
this law go through and the Supreme
Court said we're not gonna we're not
interested is because there's no there's
no standing there's like you know
where's the individual who's been wrong
that is challenging this right the
constitutionality of the law yeah I'm
afraid about abortion is that it's going
to always happen anyway it's one of
those things that they try and say like
now that it's illegal it'll stop but
like it's been what do they say nine 90
the numbers of abortions are like
staggering when you look at them those
are the ones only on record in the
United States that we know of so there
is an instance of a study that was
performed on back alley abortions which
I know is a big topic that people talk
about a lot the guy went to his deathbed
and he admitted that like half of the
numbers he had just made up just like
that he just made it up he just wanted
abortion to happen he wanted it to be
legalized he literally lied and I need
to find the study you guys are welcome
to fact check me but based on what my
understanding of the back alley abortion
thing women are more likely to die in an
actual legalized setting even with
medical care they're more likely to have
negative response to it and super regret
after the fact that any kind of back
alley abortion yeah I don't agree with
the idea that they'll happen anyway you
know we hear that a lot from a lot of
the the the the pro-abortion activists
used to be pro-choice people but I don't
know where they went because I still
consider myself pro-choice but uh the
argument is that it'll more of you know
oh it'll happen anyway I'm like I I
don't believe that's true I believe it
may you know there was like that that
Viral instance I think I don't know who
it was they held up a coat hanger you
know we're we're going back to that or
whatever and I'm like that's messed up
I'm not a fan of that at all but uh I
think you know roaming majority of women
would just have babies but what would
happen would they get like criminalized
the ones that tried to get into what
what this law says is that someone can
sue if they find out someone aided or
got an abortion and they can they can be
award up to like 10 grand I think it is
yeah but not the woman herself right oh
you can't you can't sue the woman you
can sue the doctor it is it is really
clever what they did so apparently it
used to be that these laws always got
struck down because the state had no
right to intervene in medical procedures
and so the state is saying the law
actually bars the state from enforcing
this it only allows for lawsuits where
civil cases are brought by other
citizens so that's apparently how they
are planning to get around this but
again they're acting like it's the end
of Roe v Wade but like you said this was
this was dropped because of lack of
standing in which case it could be
another week or or you know when it goes
into effect I think was it like
September or you know it went into
effect yesterday right on the first
right so we get for someone right now
just be like okay I'm suing and then
there's Supreme Court could be like yep
you can't do it and they will yeah and
and we'll go on uh the you know the the
law will be prevented from from taking
effect and they'll go into lawsuit and I
mean I don't think it's gonna change
anything in the courts um but it is a
necessary step you know you know my
issue is with the whole thing you know
I don't know where the line is that you
allow the government to say we can
mandate somebody provide their body to
somebody else I don't know where that
line is where the government is allowed
to intervene in that capacity and I'm
very scared about what that means when
we accept the government can intervene
in that capacity so let's just say so
here's the conundrum a woman uh uh you
know ends up you know pregnant and
there's a health risk a very serious
health risk and she's devastated by this
she desperately wants to have children
and she's been she's struggling with it
and so they go to the doctor and the
doctor says the baby will not survive
and neither will you like our only
option right now is termination and then
what you got to file petition to the
state
or is that is that an exemption in the
Texas law it's an exemption so the
doctor can then incest rape health of
the mother are all Exempted from this
law that's when you just said the incest
and rape and when you said this law was
very cleverly crafted this law was very
cleverly I would I wouldn't say out
clever may be the wrong word I think
perhaps the answer that is fairly solid
solid yeah so they don't want this law
to get struck down by the typical well
no no no uh uh ways that has been struck
down in the past it's not about striking
down does that mean to say that they're
actually creating a window for use for
abortion as use of as contraception
if there if there was a medical
exemption meaning you can get a
termination due to the health of the
mother incest or rape well after six
weeks before six weeks anyone can have
one there's no restrictions for before
six that means this is only after the
six week Mark that means this this the
bill is actually saying women are free
to use abortion as a form of
contraception absolutely wow as until
until uh six weeks and then is that six
weeks from conception
I was just reading about this because
sometimes it's not until two weeks after
your last period that you can actually
conceive so they'll think they're
pregnant for two weeks and they don't
actually get pregnant and then all of a
sudden they're pregnant well it's the
heartbeat bill so it's not actually
about six weeks it's about if they can
detect a heartbeat then you can't get an
abortion
unless there's exceptions you know in
those in those regards it's it's it uh
so here's the conundrum
does the state then say sorry we don't
care about the circumstances or whatever
it may be outside of these exemptions we
are going to mandate your body is is
provided to this other independent you
know living oh could you confirm two
weeks conception typically occurs about
two weeks after your last period begins
all I know is that in case any one of
the viewers who are like why are you
guys talking about this our friend Jack
besobic made it clear since men can get
pregnant now
that's correct and I was like that was
that was one of the most genius tweets I
ever saw it was like if men could get
pregnant we can talk about abortion yes
but now it's it's are you a birthing
person
but not talking about this law which was
what people were saying gen saki the
president they all talked about how this
is a threat to the rights of women so
the birthing person was not used today
so now we are back to women are the ones
getting pregnant which I think for the
trans Community is incredibly
transphobic I just I just I just I this
is actually played I talked with Glenn
and we had a really really great
conversation about it because I was just
like I hear all your arguments I agree
with a lot of your
um you know your your um I agree with
your starting point and where your
arguments are coming from
but then I think about the government
saying at this point in time that
independent living creature that is
living off of your blood and using your
body well we're going to make sure that
that stays that way and I'm like man but
this is my body I have One Life to Live
you know I don't want anybody to be like
I'm going to provide that body to
somebody else by force and I know a lot
of people don't like slippery slope
arguments but could there be a point
where it's like there's a there's a
there's an accident the government says
well the you crashed your car and the
person you hit you both have the same
blood type so we're gonna mandate you
give blood to keep them alive like at
what point are they then going to get
more and more invasive because
entertaining the idea the government has
a right to intervene that you provide
your body to someone else for some moral
reason well the person is going to die
and we can't let a life die especially
when you have the opportunity to provide
something to save them so we're going to
mandate you do then we have to start
having arguments about how much of your
body is welcome to be you know given to
somebody else now of course I know the
argument the response to this is simply
that like pregnancy is a unique
circumstance outside of injury so we
could easily carve that out and say
pregnancy especially arising from the
individual choices like because rape is
Exempted this is a woman who made a
choice got pregnant and now is
responsible for that action I understand
that I understand that I'm just there's
like a Libertarian wall that substantial
for me and I'm like I don't know how you
get past that for me morally I don't
know well I think Libertarians as like a
even as a political party their platform
is pro-choice I think most Libertarians
philosophy the oh okay yeah Dave Smith
is pro-life how could you be libertarian
and be pro-life yeah because their
argument is that this the state
Libertarians do believe in the state and
they believe that like one of the most
one of the Paramount things of this of
the state's mission is to protect life
what kind of life though so like uh we
have a government that is trying to make
sure people can live
you know and it's one of the goals of
government to prevent death so stop
someone from murdering somebody else and
that's why they're pro-life because they
view the baby with a heartbeat as its
own Independent Living entity it has its
own DNA it has its own heartbeat it is
growing and developing and at that point
we're moving it from the womb it would
terminate it in which case you know you
can't do that but I do have a question
in the capacity then would there be a
law that says the women can remove the
baby
at around five months when the baby
becomes viable outside of the wound and
then put into care and then adopted you
know what I mean because if the real
issue is killing the baby then once the
baby comes to a point where they know
the the the fetus fetus to be viable you
know outside of the womb could it then
be removed
like not to kill it but to actually let
it grow and live and flourish very risky
option yeah it is I know I don't think
most people most parents don't want to
have a preemie that's like you know but
but think about the argument if the
argument is that you can't end the life
I get it then what if it doesn't end the
life yeah and you then sever it from you
know the womb
I I don't see that as a viable
alternative to the problem here but if
the baby can live isn't that I don't
think that's guaranteed at the five
month Mark it's not guaranteed so then
would there be a legal debate over like
well at six months actually you can you
know they can do a C-section and or or
or or or woman to force labor and then
the baby can be premature and then be
treated to grow and survive because it
works
it doesn't kill the baby then right so
is it abortion or is it wouldn't be
abortion induced premature labor right
or adoption yeah it'd be an early
pregnancy induced pregnancy or induced
uh labor yeah the challenge I think that
we're dealing with is uh the reality of
what it means to be a living entity
trying to ask ourselves questions about
individual sovereignty bodily autonomy
but also the fact that we are biological
entities that use our bodies for
reproduction
and then what does it mean that when a
woman gets pregnant
there are two individuals involved
that's how the law views it especially
in car accidents and murder cases if the
woman's pregnant there's two entities
and then how do you how do you determine
rights for people who are attached to
each other I'll I'll give you another
wild crazy scenario conjoined twins and
you know uh they're both legally
carrying firearms in the good old state
of West Virginia but then one of the
conjoined twins in a fit of rage just
freaks out and shoots somebody in Cold
Blood wow do you then put the other twin
into prison
oh like serious I'm I'm not I'm not
saying no that's that's a fascinating
you've got it um
I'm simply bringing this up to show the
the problem of trying to guarantee
Liberties to an individual when they're
joined together so I don't have the
answer so basically we need a law that
says conjoined twins cannot possess
Firearms ah yeah like that's how you get
away with it if you have someone on an
Inc on an intubator and they're
unconscious they and you're like their
family member you have the right to pull
the plug on that machine I believe right
in Most states if no not not this was
the was it the Terry yeah yeah there's
there's states where you can't do it no
matter okay that's similar to abortion
because the baby can't speak for itself
it's essentially unconscious in your
inside of you and you have full control
of its breathing and it's so you you
have to make the decision whether it's
going to get the plug pulled or not then
there's euthanasia yeah and I'm just
like man I do not have the like
I don't know I had friends flat out who
say when I hit 72 and if I start having
we talk about dementia before we went on
yeah they were like I am flying myself
to Switzerland and I am they're like I
am not going to go through that myself
I'm not going to put my family through
that
um I I it's already daunting to have
like a 40 year old friend say oh no
that's the plan
um but but people yeah I would encourage
them to uh research psilocybin before
they do that I hear that that's good for
DeMent that helps dementia clear the
plaque off the uh the neurons
actually I think it's THC THC will eat
the plaque off the neurons in your brain
I don't know about that Ian yeah there's
video there's video of It Go on YouTube
and watch THC eating eating is THC the
one that actually gets you stoned or is
that the okay I always get my acronyms
confused all of these things I think
bring us to a very very simple point
it's like that that I think with a judge
talking about porn he says you know when
you see it yeah cannabinoids remove
plaque from also there's there's uh the
way referred to it is there's the the uh
particle form and the waveform of an
argument the particle form is where we
can easily quantify what is good and
what is bad and we say this goes in the
bad section this goes in the good
section like Thou shalt not kill we know
that's bad and you know but well I guess
then we got to carve out for like
self-defense and we got to cover up for
like you know Warfare and things where
we find justifiable death okay well well
there's some things that are clearly bad
you know don't attack people unprovoked
for no reason bad section then when it
comes to how do we
deal with the Liberties of individuals
when there's more than one individual in
the circumstance that can't be removed
from it and we're like you know what
there is no easily quantifiable way to
define define this and that's why I
would just call describe more as the
waveform it it takes a massive gradient
of different opinions in different areas
and there's you know there's no middle
there really is no middle because if
you're if you're pro-choice and that's
something I recognize there's going to
be abuse of the system there's going to
be people who are like I'm just gonna
use abortion as contraception and I'm
like well that's wrong right but I'm
worried about the government getting it
wrong I'm worried about someone being
like I have this problem I need an
exemption and the government going nah
and you're like why do I have to ask you
it's my life I'm honestly not concerned
if some guy I don't know kills his own
baby that I don't know in India I just
don't care right now do you care really
yes that someone somewhere you've never
heard of is destroying an unborn baby
that you've never heard of somewhere
what does that even have to do with you
in the universe though because I'm not
selfish but it has nothing to do
that's a lot to do if you get involved
you're you're selfish no what does it
have to do with you man see I believe I
believe life exists for the purpose of
creating complex systems out of free
energy and I believe that when you look
to what what we should do and what is
good good is creation protection
development progression and bad is
destruction and Chaos too much good is
cancer no too much creation is cancer
right so that's why there's there's
there's there's good within evil there's
evil within the within good there's yin
yang there's destruction good there's
Creation with an evil so so uh right uh
cancer is is is is is is disorder it's
like is evil creation but cancer is
disorder right the human body exists in
a well as a well-ordered machine that
destroys cancerous cells it's part of
the process to to ensure that it it
persists but when it when the machine
breaks and cancer develops it's actually
destroying the system and preventing the
growth and development of new complex
systems so when I hear stories about
people somewhere else doing horrible
things and destroying things I'm like
this goes against what I view life is
here to be doing they are causing
massive destruction that's that's a
negative to uh the goals of of
development creation progress Etc so I
think it's bad and I and and it's not
just about me the world isn't about me
and my perception what I want I don't
just exist so that I can have things I
want the world to genuinely improve and
be better and I hope that there's a
future out there in 100 200 years of
humans traveling the stars and
continuing the job development of
organizing energy into complex systems
and then eventually they ascend into a
higher being of a greater level of
development and then eventually human
entity whatever it is evolved develops
creates robots something else that then
starts creating its own universes as the
next phase of the creation of complex
systems
destroying things breaking things for no
reason makes me mad but there is a
reason that that is to protect the woman
for abortion anyways the odd is the idea
but but I agree with that right if
there's a woman who would die or it
would cause negative it would cause
destruction then we intervene if it's a
woman who's simply saying I'm going to
destroy I'm like that's bad the problem
is if the government gets it wrong and
they do all the time I don't want the
government involved and I understand
that it'll be abused which is a very
difficult moral position but I air
towards the libertarian side because I'm
scared of what government does with too
much power yeah right I used to have
pretty much your exact perspective on
that like what do I care if somebody has
an abortion in whatever reasons they
choose I had a pretty decent Lefty
indoctrination at University
but that changed when I uh when my son
was born
going through that process of pregnancy
and birth and then taking care of
something that small and fragile totally
reversed my so I don't think that you
can necessarily have that change of
perspective unless you go through that
yourself because I mean that's at least
where I'm coming from I mean you had a
very elaborate explanation for your
perspective but for me it's very
personal
um and going through that myself it
totally changed my perspective of
abortion I hope your wife has watched
right now because that's yes that's the
sweetest thing I have heard yeah
I want a baby that was that was great I
loved that we had uh in the first time
in our first incubation of the baby of
the of the chicken eggs I had 12 eggs
at one point one of the AGS started to
rot and I didn't know which one and I
looked online and I checked the data and
I asked some people and they said here's
what you could look for but they were
all identical when I candled them I took
the light and put the eggs and I smelled
them
and there was more than one that was
probably rotten and then I was like damn
what do I do because they explode they
can burst because the bacteria grows in
a minute and then it could infect the
other eggs so you've got to get it out
of the incubator and so I said I candled
as many as I could these look to be fine
and I'm gonna I'm gonna hopefully I'm
getting the right ones and then when I
took them out one of them may have
actually been a viable baby oh baby and
I felt so bad that this this life was
growing and you could see it and one of
them was black like it was it was like
there were a couple of them just black
came out like bacteria and gross and so
I was like I had to do that to preserve
the development the growth and the
creation and I knew the risk was going
to be that I could I could actually kill
one of the new baby chicks and I may
have and it was a miserable feeling and
I feel absolutely distraught over it and
it was just a chicken and now we have
these three little baby chicks that jump
around and playing and doing the little
chicken thing and we opened the cage and
they jump out and they're jumping all
around and they're very nice and they
flap their little wings and they're
horrible and they're living and I want
to protect them and so when I think
about the issue of you know life and you
know all this stuff I I absolutely feel
that way about other babies like I don't
just hold chickens to high esteem I'm
like it is it is a is a painful feeling
man if you I couldn't imagine what it
must be to go through that having to
make these decisions or whatever for a
person who's had to go to a clinic and
deal with the stuff
is these are hard moral questions man
honestly I am not a priest this has been
the most
um
unemotional abortion conversation I've
ever been part of and that's and it
makes me think like how many more
conversations could we have as a society
where we all have very strong opinions
and what is a more controversial subject
right an abortion and and and and we
disagree at the table but boy oh boy was
this such a this is like an example of
Civility it was very nice to be part of
yeah I like that it's the Ben Shapiro
thing that facts don't care about your
feelings I think that this is one of
those conversations that we need to be
able to have because I know that I
disagree with so many people and they're
not going to change my mind and I'm
probably not going to change theirs but
you were talking about cancer Ian and
you're also talking about maybe like a
little baby in India you just don't
really care what happens to them and I
think that if you consider the fact this
is a very cliche but if you consider the
fact that if you're going to take a
child out of the equation you have no
idea what their potential is they could
literally cure cancer but it doesn't
matter if they cure cancer or not
because if they can make one person's
life better over the course of their
life whether they have Down syndrome or
something or if they just become a
parent who makes a positive difference
in the world for their own kids you're
removing that from the equation without
ever giving them a shot at life that's
what I have an issue with it's not
really emotional it's like you don't
F round I mean the potential of human
life they could be Hitler for sure yeah
obviously if they're born to a bad
situation it could be way worse there's
there's good and there's bad people and
um but I but you know I I thought about
something especially at why I oppose the
death penalty is because I just I I read
about I read stories and I read about
people's experiences and I was reading
about death row
and it was like a guy who was going on
death row and at the very last minute
they they they they put a a a a a halt
or whatever on the on the execute stay
on the execution and then later turned
out the guy was wrongly convicted and
then I was like I could only imagine
being told we are going to slowly walk
you to a painful death knowing that soon
what makes you you the uniqueness of you
would be snuffed out and you were
innocent and I was like that is one of
the most horrifying things I I feel like
a person could ever experience it's like
a mock execution it's like you have no
power you have done nothing to deserve
this and we are going to end you now and
this guy was you know there's a bunch of
stories like this but I was like wow I
could not ex I I I believe killing is
wrong yeah I believe that human beings
are all you know you know what's funny
we can talk about a Bitcoin you know
crypto and it's a unique hash code and
how there can be trillions upon
trillions all of these unique codes
humans are like
to to to the to the tenth power to the
hundredth power unique every little bit
about them from their ideas and their
developments to the words they use the
way they speak to the color of the hair
all become this extremely unique
you know what it's like if you have to
be you know two two pieces of matter
can't occupy the same space it's almost
like the same time two formations cannot
be the same in this universe so that we
have we're forced to be unique by
becoming different than our surroundings
I just mean to say that uh you know to
quote Dr Manhattan or to paraphrase Dr
Manhattan that you know with all the
matter in the universe that could have
come together a woman loves a man she
had every reason to hate and all that
came was you a miracle something that
shouldn't exist brilliant comic and
Brilliant movie and so I each each
individual person is my dad when I was
young I think we lost our cat or
something happened to a cat and I was
like oh it's really sad um the cat he's
so sad my dad was like it's a cat and I
remember like he's based in like a
fireman like a legit Blue Collar dude
just like yeah that puts it in
perspective it was a cat like what are
we doing here on Earth it didn't it
wasn't like I say you're saying all life
is valuable but you're talking about
human life and you're saying killing is
wrong I was talking about chicken bro I
was talking about a chicken that made me
feel miserable because I accidentally
made it it's a chicken that's that was
you is a hierarchy of life though sure
we respect all life like we shouldn't be
killing things but clearly like we do
hunt we eat meat absolutely so yeah so
just to make sure we're not egalitarian
in that sense like all life is the same
it's definitely not definitely not you
were saying there's practical reasons
not to eat people you were so obsessed
yeah
diseases yeah yeah but also it's just
like although I wouldn't taste good I'm
pretty sure you said pretty sure killing
was wrong and I imagine you met like
killing humans was wrong when you were
talking about it but but like is it now
murder is wrong because killing enemy
soldiers is Right according to our
society is moral standard probably not I
wouldn't say it's right but I would say
it's Justified it's Justified it's good
for our friends I wouldn't say it's good
oh it is good in war if you kill the
enemy and you survive it is good well in
the sense that like it's better than he
kill you yes but I don't think it's not
good I I don't think oh gosh that would
be dangerous as a society if we say like
it is good that we killed all those
arrests that was necessary Justified
killing is wrong better he killed I
killed him and then he killed me but but
murder you could say murder is wrong
Destruction for no uh so destruction uh
uh for the purpose of Destruction
Destruction for the purpose of
protecting life is different when we
kill a chicken to eat it it's because
it's part of the process of organizing
free energy into complex systems and in
order to survive so we eat we we kill
and eat but if someone went around with
the with a with a a 410 and just popping
off people's chickens they'd arrest them
and lock them up that's why I'm going
after those animals that are eating my
chickens the boxes although he's
although he's doing it to eat in fact
the mom was doing it to feed her Cubs
she's just not doing it for my chickens
the fox is Justified so we have dogs
yeah I get it it makes me think like is
it at what point is it murder because I
think murder is inherently wrong that
pretty much everybody agrees in society
Society so are you murdering the baby is
is it murder or is it killing of a of a
life form that's in development like at
what point is it considered murder when
you do it for no reason other than you
know what I didn't want this to happen
and whoops I'm not responsible so I'll
just you know
I guess I just feel like the choice to
abort is at best a poor executive
decision on behalf of the mother
agreed you think it's better to give up
for adoption
I don't know I don't know that's that's
really tough to say I
I guess there are some circumstances
where that would be the case but not
always maybe not even the majority you
know I I I I so want like people not to
get abortions but man there's literally
in my mind I keep just hitting a
Libertarian wall of like I don't
understand why the government intervenes
and stops someone from making a decision
that I have no business being involved
in other than to protect innocent life
but then I don't know the circumstances
there's no way I could know the
circumstances that means there's going
to be a lot of abuse and I'm like damn
that sucks I have no idea what to do
yeah but that is the role of government
at least have we have we have it ordered
right we do ask the government to step
in you mentioned Terry shivo we asked
the government to step in in those
circumstances where the vulnerable do
not have the the ability to protect
themselves otherwise let's just kill the
homeless right who who advocates for the
home that's very different man why why
what's what's wrong with them they're
they're they're strung out on drugs
they're uh that they're not coherent
they're just contributing not
contributing to society they pose a
danger so a lot of them so let's just if
we just get rid of them what's is that
murder no it's just it's just calling
yeah right but no of course the
government steps in as like someone has
to protect these people from those who
would do them harm
what when these International Elites
talk about humans is if they're
livestock overpopulating yeah they view
it very in a very utilitarian manner of
like well if for the betterment of
mankind you know we've got to do
something about acts well what about
that yeah like your libertarian
sensibilities were saying you don't want
the government to get involved with that
well you know the the China one child
policy the there are people here in
America who who talk about population
control very comfortably and the rules
that we should have of this one child
per family you have to be a way to go
with number two on the way you have to
be a sociopath
to entertain the notion of calling human
beings because as humans we strive to
protect each other and to flourish and
to love and to live and we hold
ourselves to the highest hierarchical
standard in terms of life and hence the
genre of post-apocalyptic movies and
books from uh uh Hunger Games to the uh
the the maze Maze Runner and uh the the
choo choo train in the snow they're all
that same idea but what I want to just
mention that I did ask Alex Jones this
question when we were when we were on
the show and I said what if they're
right what if we are expanding too
rapidly ignorant to our own impending
demise because we're like yeast in a
bottle eating the sugars and farting
ourselves to death what if there needs
to be some kind of intervention to make
sure Humanity survives and Alex said
it's a tough question I think about it
you know ask myself the question every
day and I just don't know it seems like
there's we are two different things at
one point we're desperate if we're
hungry and starving we become desperate
violent wild animals seeking for our
survival but then when we get past the
base needs we become this like
effervescent thinking machine that can
create and solve will create problem
create and solve problems create
Solutions and that's that's not there
when you're like a desperate animal
that's just thinking about food like a
North Korean citizen or something no but
this is the whole argument of lock
versus Hobbes this is Jean-Jacques
Rousseau we've been struggling with this
for for 2 000 years as to the the true
nature of man is is it this absolute
Beast of a thing that is tamed by his
peers and by Society or is it this
wonderful loving peaceful thing and
society makes it this absolute animal
and I go both ways now that I live in
the country and now I think society
makes people worse for a while I used to
think we were animals and Society made
people better but now I look at cities I
look at my hometown of New York I look
at DC I'm like I think I think Society
sometimes has a bad a a negative
influence on the individual so but but
you're absolutely right we're never
gonna We're not gonna solve it in the
few minutes we have left but we've been
discussing that for literally thousands
of years the nature of man what if just
like randomly at the ends of the Super
Chat we read and then all of a sudden
everyone in the world's holding hands
and seeing songs like to buy the world
to Coke and we all Ascend into a beings
of pure energy see you in my dreams
tonight you guys that's why I came here
tonight
let's read the super chats everybody we
read the super chats smash the like
button if you haven't already subscribe
to the channel share the show go to
timcast.com be a member because we'll
have a bonus segment member segment
because there's a bunch of stuff we
didn't get into because we just kind of
you know roll with it so
all right let's see
harito says I put my finger in a cow's
mouth it wasn't as cool as Ian said it
was hairy toe I don't know if I believe
you or not I think he's lying I think so
too I think he liked it
all right let's see Nikolai says nursing
shortage applied to eight different
hospitals in Philly NJ area three
positions at each only heard back from
Penn and Jefferson interesting
Blake larum says am I in the right place
I thought this was shimcast IRL when is
Sheamus coming back no hopefully soon
we're talking about that today I'm gonna
get it back soon
salty racer says Ian just when I think
you can't say anything Dumber you say
something else and totally redeem
yourself
cyclical nature of me well I only I only
read it because it's a Dumb and Dumber
joke right that's awesome
Ian B says Tim loved your recent show
with Elijah consider inviting Chris
valatan on your show he is a pastor at a
large Church in Reading California
called Bethel check him out he talks
about culture and politics interesting
cool we will look into him yeah
Stalin zapedes says can you please tell
liberals to stop calling us latinx most
of us hate that we still have common
sense here love you guys keep it good
job
tanks that's great I think about it
every day
Nick Sweeney says Tim yesterday you said
you didn't care for the story of Destiny
I would like you and Ian if he wants to
give the story of Destiny another chance
part one oh so there's gonna be another
one in here okay so we'll see oh okay
here we go he says the story has gotten
really good over the last year turning
old enemies into allies xenophobia
political Intrigue and more I would
recommend the YouTuber let's visit my
name is Biff for a condensed but
in-depth overview of the story not don't
like it I don't like the story because
it's hopeless uh if you're not familiar
with the video game Destiny is like the
humans were thriving because this big
object came and granted them like
technology and allowed them to flourish
and colonize the solar system but then
the darkness comes and then human human
civilization collapses and the old
colonies collapse so there's a really
cool aspect of the space-faring humanity
that ended up faltering the problem is
after several years because I wanted the
game come out like 2014 or something
I've been playing Destiny one the
problem is that humans have done nothing
to succeed it's like I turned the game
on and they're like our life is
miserable and the city's worse off than
it ever was and I'm like so we suck
that's what I got from Walking Dead that
show I couldn't I stopped watching it
because I want I wanted I wanted to see
a story where it's like after the
collapse and you're sad you see the
progress and success and and the
rebuilding and said the story is just
like well seven years later we suck
we're worse off than we ever were it's
worse than it was when it started you're
not winning and I'm like I don't want to
play a game where you gradually lose
everyone the story is just bad yes
September 2014. there could have been so
much stuff where like by now there could
have been like the city's bigger you
know I mean the city is bigger because
they've opened more areas but like story
wise they're reclaiming territory by now
Earth should be controlled completely by
humanity and they should be setting up
alternate cities and it should they'll
be so amazing I'd be like this is so
cool
people need a Redemptive quality in
there whatever there was that's why
people love Tony Soprano or the guy from
Breaking Bad right they're evil
characters and there's no hope but they
they they they give a sense of
redemption that people strive for yeah
womans says my work is offering a 200
drawing by turning in a copy of a vax
card but does that mean to take it away
from you or that like they'll pull it
out and then say you won copy of your
Vex card so you photocopy it oh a copy
throw it in the Hat and I missed that
one I should read more um
200 bucks I'd throw my card in there
yeah if I had one there's nothing on it
but I'd throw it in all right
the citizen journalist says Tim I want
to thank you you really inspired me I've
officially launched the citizen
journalist.ca and have published my
first article about a canadian-wide
nurse walkout in a rally against vaccine
mandates and passports awesome that's
nice
all right Roger Eiser says on Mark
Levin's radio show earlier he had on
Larry Elder Larry mentioned the Dianne
Feinstein's Health was not good guess
who gets to pick the senate seat if
she's not present Governor Elder whoa if
he wins yeah so I was doing well in the
polls well right now they're swinging a
little bit towards Newsome hmm But the
the race is already on and I looked at
I've been tracking the political data
for returned mail-in ballots and I gotta
say
it seems really bad for Democrats uh the
reason is right now 53 percent of belts
returned are Democrat ballots
then you've got 47 which are a mix of
independent and Republican among
Independents about two-thirds don't
favor Democrats so if we were to just
extrapolate off of the top level data
Democrats do have a substantial lead but
to say that Republicans are at 40
percent perhaps in terms of return
mail-in ballots Republicans vote on
Election Day not by mail yeah so that's
what we might end up seeing is come
September 14th a major burst of all of
the remaining Republicans and not enough
Democrats but Democrats will come out
too so we'll see we'll see I just want
to know who the Californian is who look
around and is like this is good the meme
with the fire right this is for us
I have anecdotal data right I'm saying
that it's sort of an oxymoron I have uh
anecdotes of people saying that
Democrats they know in California are
like I'm voting to recall I don't care
just yeah because he's corrupt not they
don't care who it is Larry Elder will
only be there for a year and he won't
have that much power them uh but they're
like anything's better than Newsom at
this point and Gavin's kind of kind of
scary like he does remind me of Patrick
Bateman yeah
he really is uncomfortable let's say
this let's say that all Independents and
Republicans are like I'm not voting for
this guy we want to recall
and 53 of Democrats all say we want
Newsom to stay that's 53 to 47 and
that's mailing mail-in votes so far then
I think it stands to reason because
Independents are underrepresented here
that come election day Republicans will
find that boost and percentage to flip
this they need only to swing about 3.1
percent
however when you factor in the fact that
many Democrats also don't like Newsom
and may actually vote to recall
the actual in favor of Newsome vote
might only be 52 51 50 49 it could be 20
for all we know so I would just say
based off the current levels I think
it's actually good news for Republicans
but it's not by no means a guarantee and
may still I actually think the
probability is a Newsome's favor to be
honest I don't wish any ill on Senator
Feinstein I'm just wondering how old she
is
88.88 she's 88. whoa born 1933 wow I
mean I remember when she ran last time
people said
really what year um
she wasn't up this last time I think it
was 18 I think she must have been up and
people like what year was she born uh
1933 1930. I remember people say he was
old enough to be doing the Lindy Hop
yeah I think so I think she was I think
she was too old my parents said the
Lindy Hop and they were born much after
that she was probably in her I'm like
well I guess 35 year olds Lindy Hop but
yeah she was probably yeah the Lindy Hop
yeah what about the Charleston no that
came out in the Roaring 20s which we're
having now yeah so maybe her older
sisters or something did that yeah but
that means when she was she was a little
kid we'll do it later on the uh we'll
have to reinvent it yeah when she was a
little kid her parents were you know
it's like when when your parents played
like Led Zeppelin for you or whatever or
I don't know what did it play for you
um
yeah like like the music of like the 50s
and 60s yeah yeah
um Talking Heads a lot of Talking Heads
Crosby Stills Nash and Young spring love
those vocals Generations your parents
were listening to the Springsteen oh
yeah pretty cool parents are your
parents like my age well one parent
actually my mom could have just played
Springsteen and Brian Adams on repeat
I remember Cat Stevens Zeppelin uh uh
three dog night um that was great
they're great yeah she's CCR oh yeah did
you see Abba's coming out with a new
album today which everyone loves Abba
everyone jokes that they hate it but
everyone loves that there's great
documentaries watch some documentaries
because they are cool they're really
cool people let's read this one we got
Anthony Epley says on PTSD and Shadow
trauma is true look up Dr John L Riggs
and his studies dealing with veterans
also he did a little stint with Lee uh
with uh lee Oyster Cult and is it lie
Oyster Oyster Cult is Big about
explaining to Veterans new veterans that
no matter your age you can still go
forward and do more in your life good
for him very cool
Creighton says there is news the
governor of Washington state is
considering a nationwide mandate that
you must show your vaccination you must
show you are vaccinated to enter any bar
or restaurant our state is trying to be
more left than NY or CA Statewide yeah I
saw that Statewide yeah no man
John McHugh says Joe Rogan is already
feeling better and has more viewers in
the media bashing him and that's why
they bash him yeah
I thought it was funny when I was like
reading all these articles and I'm like
man Joe Rogan's Instagram videos more
views on all of those articles combined
wow this whole thing has made me wonder
if he's actually become uncancelable I
think he has yeah is he is he resistant
to cancellation I I but I actually think
we're getting to a point where cancel
culture is failing
because concerns me is the banks if the
banks make it so you can't have a bank
account anymore yeah but crypto right
[ __ ] like
I don't care yeah but but there's a
level of of uh not even convenience of
just functionality um the banks but also
the apps right Lou there are people who
Uber won't let them have their download
um you know PayPal won't let them use
their their app because of their
politics and so how do you survive in
modern I just said so casually if the
banks cancel you that's like a violation
of human rights in my opinion absolutely
yeah ah all right we got it we have a
correction uh Ian shop says for your
information regeneron is the
manufacturer of the monoclonal antibody
uh is not the name of the product ah
okay yes stand corrected that was a
mistake because everybody kept saying
regeneron there's a really funny video a
super a super uh composite compilation
of trump and it's like an it's it's yeah
Supercut and it's supposed to be like an
80s commercial where he's like regeneron
and then it's like you know just like an
80s commercial you'd see on TV it's
really funny like Max Headroom I thought
regeneron was what Dee was selling and
Always Sunny in Philadelphia when she
got caught in the Ponzi scheme did
anyone watch right remember that episode
watch it again he has a great show
horrible I can only watch a few episodes
talk about no redeeming quality oh my
gosh it's coming back too is it yeah
thank goodness yeah we need it we do
yeah
DW says the Donald split in 2020 when we
were banned from Reddit patriots.win is
under investigation and based out of the
UK find the real mod team and community
at save americachat.com also Joe Kent
2022. wait you're saying that Patriot
patriots.win is run out of the UK
Pirate Radio that that's what so the
Donald became yeah
but it became they went to their own
website.win oh okay so now they're
saying it's running the UK so it's not
run by Americans that's what's happening
interesting
Morgan dust is going to get a shout out
to a mom-and-pop skate shop burning
spider Stoke company in KC they're
pressing their own boards Now by
American made that is absolutely correct
by American Maiden it's very cool
pressing forwards that sounds cool yeah
yeah
yeah I always try when we were doing
custom boards to buy American-made ones
because you know they do they take the
wood from Canada ship it to China make a
board ship it to the US stupidest thing
I ever heard I'll just pay somebody to
make it here I don't mind paying more
for American that's what we got to do
because you're you're investing in
yourself and your country and it's worth
it people got to do it
all right let's see
molon labe says Tim Community also has a
different indication of use age 16 and
older per fact sheet in FDA while Pfizer
eua vax's age 12 and older the confusion
may be to protect Pfizer from legal
liability but who knows seems weird
or it might just be that Community is a
marketing marketing product or the legal
distinction so it's approved and they
they're keeping the eua because it's for
12 and older and Community isn't
it seems really weird like I honestly it
might just be a Remnant like a like a
remnant of vestigial bureaucracy that
they did it this way because when they
say the vaccine can be used
interchangeably I'm like okay so what's
the big deal what what the other ones
lose eua I guess I don't know I think I
think someone's going to make a lot of
money off the name Community could be
wrong about that but I wish I would
about the URL I'm just I'm just ready
for Spike backs
that's a way better name yes
I don't even know how to pronounce it
imagine the commercial where it's like
some just like some Chad bro and he's
like Spike facts
[Laughter]
Spike backs
X says frankly the six weeks is too
short ovulation is like two weeks after
last period but they count from last
period a lot of women will have less
than two weeks to make their choice
eight to twelve weeks is better but the
issue isn't the laws in about six weeks
about heartbeat as soon as the heartbeat
is detected they they can't do anything
so age 12 weeks wouldn't work because
I'd always be a heartbeat
what mother here's the heartbeat and
goes oh no kid like I just I I can't
wrap my head around that yeah I know I
know that there are some people in very
desperate situations and you know they
might end up losing their own life I
unders I understand that but just like
you were saying Tim just for the sake of
a of destroying I don't understand that
it goes back to how I was saying earlier
man I think that people are two
different things we've got the
compassionate thinking beings and then
we've got this wild almost stupid animal
that we're we're like we're these
intelligent things inside of these wild
things like the the brain brain stem
creature is like the thinking
compassionate part of us and then this
body is dangerous and violent stinky and
and gets feelings wet yeah
all right we got a meat boy Adrian Curry
oh as a woman if you haven't figured out
you're pregnant by the sixth week and
aborted you deserve to have a baby wow
interesting take I kind of share that
yeah
to agree maybe three months six weeks
three months I would say Adam Fritz says
Tim my two-year-old loves watching Mr
Tim every night and named his stuffed
dog after you thanks for all you do
bringing reason to effing madness please
shout out to the Salty Army we're here
for you man thanks right on awesome
thank you so much all right picture that
stuffed dog yeah people people keep
posting salt shakers in the in the chat
yeah
[Laughter]
Anon nobody says Ian Crossland if life
begins at conception would you feel
different I.E a constitutional right
to hit on Lydia's point there are
studies that prove there was less
abortions prior to Roe v Wade there is a
lot of lies around abortion
um no it wouldn't make me feel different
because I think murder and killing are
different and destroying something
that's alive is different than murdering
a human so at some point I start to
consider the zygote a human but it's
just at what point I don't necessarily
think it's I think it's brain activity
that's my personal belief
all right let's see we got here
Aura kirena says Tim the argument you
made about women and abortion does not
take in the responsibility of the woman
and her choices Texas law make it make
it safe and rare no I I agree with that
like I I really thought I had a great
conversation with Glenn Beck because I
just like he would make all these good
points I'm like wow those are really
great points
I don't know how I reconcile government
still don't know yeah I just don't I
just a great conversation I don't know
it's like wow and I'm like wow that's
really important yes the women made the
women Woman made a choice she wasn't
using contraception
she got pregnant there are two people
involved they're now responsible someone
someone mentioned that when you uh the
Super Chat maybe we'll get to it when
you put someone in a position where
they're dependent upon you you're
responsible for them like if you caused
it like if you got into a car accident
you'd have to and you caused it you'd
have to pay the person and sometimes you
gotta pay for the rest of your life and
I'm like that's that's actually a good
point
but then man I don't know someone online
uh following the argument someone on
Twitter said um you know if women can't
have an abortion then then we need a lot
I think it meant to be snarky but then
we need a law that says the men that got
the woman pregnant should be responsible
and I was like yes I love that law I
like absolutely yes yeah like you should
be on I mean it's not it does take two
to tango so absolutely yes
did something
the old shotgun wedding legalized that's
right I just got a new shotgun also I
can I can officiate yeah turtle burger
says why does the choice in pro-choice
never apply to the choice to get
pregnant the government doesn't mandate
pregnancy why not pro responsibility
instead of stopping a heartbeat to
remedy a regret I agree with that so the
issue I brought up earlier to address
the previous point about women's choices
is that
let's say there's a genuine circumstance
where the woman has a real exemption and
then she has to submit why she's going
through this to the government the
government says no we deny that
you know what I mean I'm just like if if
I had to go to the doctor and the doctor
gave me recommendation I don't want to
have to then follow up with like a no
State appointed representative to go
file the paperwork and then be like
here's why the doctor wants to do this
procedure on my balls you know what I
mean it's like that and then and they
could be like I don't agree that you
should do this so I'm going to deny it
and I'd be like dude based on this you
should be getting this thing we're gonna
suggest that you have this operation
instead and you're like what I don't
like it yeah that's and I don't like
government I think abortion uh in in as
contraception is just like morally
repugnant and wrong I could totally
agree on that but then it's just like
man I have no I have no remedy because I
know people abuse the system you give
you give them options you're like we're
gonna we're gonna try and and be and be
right with these examinations and they
lie and it's just like
I the conclusion that I reached is that
this is a heavily cultural issue and you
cannot change it from the top down and I
feel like everyone who's arguing about
it is saying that we need to use the
government to enforce us no we need to
change the way people think about having
children and raising families and I
don't know how to do that like this TV
shows like this yeah yeah having
conversations definitely it's me says so
if you get drunk and drive killing
someone it's just an accident because
you're not responsible for actions but
beforehand if you have sex you know the
possibility of pregnancy not responsible
for actions it's a good point and so I
guess maybe there's an analogy there
where it's like the government goes to
you and says you're not not allowed to
drive because we've seen on social media
you drink a lot and we're worried you
might be a drunk driver so today you're
not going to be driving red flag law or
taking your license yeah like red flag
laws we've determined that you may
actually be crazy even though we we
haven't you know we've got a warrant so
we're taking your guns away because the
government has a right to intervene when
it comes to health issues and you're a
danger to others and they're like oh
when you've got three women pregnant
against their will on accident we're
going to order a vasectomy for you like
come on I know yeah slippery slope
arguments are often like people roll
their eyes at them but come on we've
seen the slippery slope abused way too
much by government so it's like but I I
do respect you know like the you know
Mrs caucus guys pro-life their argument
makes sense you know
I just I don't know man pro-life like
get the government to make it illegal
type stuff that's libertarian that's
what the libertarian party is pro-choice
but the mises caucus is pro-life because
they believe that that if the government
has any job it's to protect life to make
sure that you've got to Define life
that's for sure but they have a
definition of Life heartbeat
I think conception conception is their
definition I don't know their definition
okay but I I I I I I I think anybody who
argues life does not begin a conception
is just lying to you
I don't really understand I guess right
it just I guess it's a human human life
they're talking about protecting human
life yeah not not not deer not bees and
not zygotes because a zygote could be
any animal you don't know what kind of
animal it is still later in his
gestation sure but a human you know like
there's not like a lizard in a woman's
womb you know what I mean you just don't
scientifically they're identicals I
goats are identical you don't know until
later
inside a woman's womb is not going to be
a lizard cycle well obviously but no not
as not a hundred percent uh though I did
see I did watch V when I was a kid and
and so yeah a lot of weird stuff Evan
Perry says my birth mother aborted the
eldest and it caused her to rethink her
choice which is why myself and my older
brother are here today my adopted mother
can't give birth and not aborting us
worked well
there's always very serious issues
especially when it comes to like down
syndrome one of the biggest reasons they
say they should be abortion is for Down
syndrome and it's like that's Eugenics
totally I'm not saying that to be like
ah it's a no it's literally you're like
we've we've looked at we've done the
test and the genetic code reveals it's
going to be this way and you're like
remove it I uh sorry there are people
with Down Syndrome who are functioning
remember like people with Down Syndrome
are functioning members of society yeah
yeah there was this guy who was speaking
at a hearing was it a congratulations
he was like you wanted to kill me like
I'm here right now like I'm successful
and there are multiple cases of is
diagnosed Down syndrome and then the
baby is born and they're like oh my gosh
you don't have Down syndrome it's not
multiple cases it's it's five percent if
you're against the death penalty because
four percent of the time they think it's
wrong but you're okay with them aborting
babies who are misdiagnosed with Down
Syndrome five percent of the time I
think you need to rethink what do they
end up having if not they have nothing
they don't have anything they're born
they're just misdiagnosed they get it
right sometimes I do not understand the
argument about incest and rape it's such
a tiny I almost put on Twitter today and
I decided not to just because I was
being too much of an idiot to begin with
but I almost put on our which I can do
uh of saying I understand get rid of the
Down Syndrome baby because they're going
to have a tough life but you know what
it was really tough being a gay kid so
if you diagnose your baby with like a
gay gene because we're born this way I
would be okay with aborting the the gay
the gay fetuses just because I don't
really come across people don't know I'm
gay I don't talk about it but I was
waiting to see the replies of people
being like
but but why why what's the stop it right
because Down syndrome is a very
difficult life for those kids to a point
so was a lot of things so is ugly and
boy and they're hard to look at so abort
the ugly baby but the left doesn't
believe being a gay is a choice
it's not a choice you're born this way
no I'm sorry I'm sorry I was wrong the
left believes being gay is a choice
that's it sorry they actually do yeah
they think it's a social construct well
that's why the difference are you having
sex with a guy or do you want like what
makes you gay having sex with a guy
having sex with a guy or a guy wanting
to have sex with a guy no no that's
serious questions
how about we talk about super chats and
maybe we'll talk about that okay cool
okay perfect because you're getting way
too yeah it's more the the philosophy of
what it means to be gay but we should
abort them
um
all right let's see uh a lot of people
are saying like I disagree with Ian
they're very very polite each and every
one they're like Ian um I disagree with
you and humbly respect your right to
have your opinion I 100 believe you too
everybody's very no it is true most of
them are just like Ian let me try to
explain to you and you need to
understand but they disagree with you
and smart
and smart like I said this was a very
civil conversation about abortion I'm
not surprised your audience is nice yeah
we have a great audience
[Laughter]
o3ks says the only reason I need to care
about a stranger murdering a child is
that someone has to stand up for that
child and defend someone that cannot
defend themselves good people defend the
defenseless whether you know them or not
yep
all right atarka says adoption is
another problem needs to be fixed before
I believe abortion uh before I believe
abortion gets rid of because that system
is broken as well until then it should
stay but not be abused you know what
really annoys me about the the
pro-abortion crowd is that they just lie
about what pro-lifers believe
like I can talk to a conservative and
they'll be like here's my opinions on
pro-life and I'm like oh I understand
that and then I talked to a liberal and
they're like well it's because they're
racist and they hate brown people and
I'm like that that's not what they said
well they're lying to you I'm like
but their argument has been replicated
over and over by so many different
people and many different Publications
is it's just this big conspiracy of
right-wing media to claim one thing but
do another they all secretly know that
behind the scenes they have these deep
dark racist beliefs and they never
espouse them yes I'm like what yo you're
like you're lying to me like I can
disagree with someone and be like I see
here I disagree but thanks for the
conversation not with whatever that is
there was a great retweet by um
uh who retweeted this someone retreated
something I'm forgetting your name sorry
I'm forgetting who retweeted because I
just saw the retweet and uh Phil
philabonti that's who retweeted it yeah
it was uh um Michelle wolf was her name
I think oh yeah where she came out and
she was like oh yeah and you get an
abortion and someone he retweeted
someone who said I used to be pro-choice
but I changed my mind after seeing this
I saw that on Twitter I think you I
think you retweeted it too yeah because
I was just like shout your abortion like
we're like that like the salute to the
yeah nothing about being pro-choice
encourages someone to get an abortion
right yeah that's not right you
mentioned these options I think the
average right now is for every one child
up for adoption there are 26 couples
looking for yes there are serious
problems in the abortion system and I do
agree we need to fix that yeah but but I
mean and obviously I mean that's those
26 couples rotate but one child for 26
people who want a child is a huge need
for children right
um
Zach Tokar says support project Veritas
after their HQ got destroyed by the
storm I didn't hear that that's terrible
oh wow we will be supporting them and
helping them Absolutely I'll look into
that and we'll check it out after the
show
Sonny James says Ian might look into
pre-birth memories or experiences oh my
gosh they almost overwhelmingly have the
feeling of not wanting to be born and
recollect angst at the pain of being
born of the world that being said I'm
pro-life ndes get all the credit what is
that true that's crazy
actually go ahead I was in the womb and
I was like my mom was going through
labor for like 26 hours with me and I
wouldn't come out and they were like
okay we're gonna do a C-section and then
I immediately turned around and came out
like all right I was like I I knew I
just did not want to leave and I feel
like I remember them it's it's my
understanding that children aren't
actually supposed to be born in nine
months they're in a perfect world they
would be born at 12 months really yes
because they're they're technically not
ready that's why those first three
months are so strange and they're so
fragile and you know they sleep a lot
and all that stuff because the woman's
body literally cannot give birth at 12
months right it's impossible but in a
perfect world they would stay in the
womb for 12 months that's why those
first three months are so crazy like the
Denise a lot of sense you look at a
normal animal get born like the little
chicks and you know it was when my
chicks had I was like well we have to
put it near the mom because it has to
nurse and as I'm saying it I'm like oh
my God it's a chicken does it nurse
right like but like the little chick is
born and a second later it's pecking
water and it's pecking and it starts
eating but like I I watched my sheep get
born and within four minutes they're
like up and they're walking around and
then a baby is born as you experience
and it's like they're useless for this
yes
thinking about those Denise events one
of our ancient hominid ancestors like
the uh neanderthals but they were huge
they were really big and they probably
gave birth to 12 months I don't know but
maybe that's part of them
all right we'll do a couple more here
maybe the vet wolf pack says Ian the
right to life is the very first right
ever enumer enumerated by the founding
fathers it was Quantified in the
Declaration of Independence
all right no way says take some time and
look into the replication crisis it's an
ongoing issue that many fundamental
studies and many domains of science
cannot be replicated meaning they may be
totally inaccurate I have heard about
that it's it's really interesting
all right let's see
um maybe we'll just get to we'll get one
more
Brian Percival wulfric Abba fourth Snape
says I beg you to read this I am a
former Marine I don't have PTSD because
of the things I've seen I haven't
because of the things I have done
Jordan Peterson yeah there you go well
man thanks for the Super Chat and
everybody thanks for hanging out we're
gonna go do a member podcast which will
be at timcast.com and if you want to
watch it go be a member because man we
got a bunch of stuff in the works but
I'll tell you this you know I was I was
talking abandon about this a little bit
after the show
because he was like you've called me
like a Workhorse because I do the
morning show did the night show we do
the Vlog we're launching several other
shows and I was like in in between the
shows there's very little time for me to
do anything like exercise eat and then
we were doing like a live read for the
new show to get the feel for it and he
was just like the challenge is that the
more you do quality control you know it
starts to go down and I'm like that's
the challenge you know Finding good
talented people takes time and that
sucks because I'd love to snap my
fingers and be like boom look at all
this awesome stuff we're doing but we're
getting there you know the Vlog has
picked up steam we're you it's always
this you just start doing it and then
improve over time that's what we're
gonna we're gonna do so the Vlog started
with once a week and now we're getting
almost every single day we're working on
better ways to make it better and better
so check it out at youtube.comcast
Castle but we're going to do this
members podcast so don't forget to like
smash the like button subscribe to the
channel share the show with your friends
you can follow us at timcastirl you can
follow me personally at timcast uh do
you want to shout out your uh yeah
Daniel Turner PTF power of the future on
all platforms and as always thank thanks
for having me always a good conversation
yeah I'd love to have you Chris carr17
on Twitter I'm the 17th Chris Carr 17th
clone uh always a joy to be here right
on thanks man yeah you can follow me and
do you have a sorry do you have a
website you want a shout out timcast.com
right on um I wanted to you know Ian
crosson's my name playing as my game I
wanted to shout out Adam kokash that was
so cheesy dude I talked about Adam
kokesh a few days ago on the show and um
if you don't know who Adam Koka she's
he's like a uh like he's called an
activist he served in the military came
back 2008 from Iraq he was very vocal
about it and he tweeted at me I was like
hey you got some things wrong I just
wanted to clarify Adam if you're
listening I said that what he did is he
went to DC with a shotgun and protested
they used that as probable cause to
searches I said apartment it was this
house I believe not apartment and then I
said that they found suicide mushrooms
it was true in that he went to prison he
actually went to jail not prison for
four months Virginia jail another jail
and then I said when it looked like when
he got out he was brow beaten and like a
different person but what happened is he
got Shadow banned he has a channel
called Adam versus the man that has 260
000 subscribers and the videos get 600
views so they put them on some sort of
and I just thought he was gave up but
he's just and his Show's actually really
good I mean it's still Adam but also
Adam you he seems like he's chilled out
over the years like he was very fire and
angry when I first saw him now he's not
he's more of like a wiseened kind of
speaker and I took that as that the
government did it to him I think he's
just evolved Adam I love you Adam versus
the man rock and roll awesome and I
wanted to announce you guys today is our
365th episode which means that if you go
back to the first one you can listen to
a Year's worth of news every single day
for the I don't know why you would want
to do that but you can we've officially
hit 365 so wow I'm pretty pleased
awesome imagine historical archives I
know right they're gonna be like damn
this Tim pool guy hates Democrats
historical yup thanks for hanging out
everybody go to timcast.com uh become a
member and we'll see y'all there bye
guys